What's better than a well-marbled ribby sizzling on the barbecue? A well-marbled ribby sizzling on the barbecue that was carefully selected by an Instacart shopper and delivered to your door. A well-marbled ribby you ordered without even leaving the kitty pool. Whatever groceries your summer calls for, Instacart has you covered. Download the Instacart app and enjoy $0 delivery fees on your first three orders. Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Instacart, groceries that over-deliver. Hey there, welcome to your second drink of beach games.
有什么比在烧烤架上滋滋作响、大理石花纹完美的肋眼牛排更好的呢？那就是由Instacart购物者精心挑选并送到您家门口的、在烧烤架上滋滋作响、大理石花纹完美的肋眼牛排。甚至不用离开儿童戏水池就能订购到这样一块肋眼牛排。无论您的夏天需要什么杂货，Instacart都能满足您。下载Instacart应用程序，享受前三单免运费服务。服务费、排除条款和条件适用。Instacart，为您提供超值配送的杂货服务。嘿，欢迎来到您的第二杯海滩游戏特饮。
Lady, did you know that this episode was originally titled, Coal Walk? Cole Walk, I didn't. Yeah, that's just one of the little extra tidbits I uncovered. I found the original pitch document for this episode, and that's what it was called. I also went into our mailbag, and we got some fun letters about this one. I like it. I have a couple of fun candy bag talking heads I want to share, and the first one is right at the top of the episode.
女士，你知道这一集最初的标题是《走火炭》吗？《走火炭》，我不知道。是的，这只是我发现的一点额外花絮。我找到了这一集的原始提案文件，标题就是那个。我还翻看了我们的邮件袋，收到了一些关于这一集的有趣来信。我喜欢。我有几个有趣的“糖果袋”访谈片段想分享，第一个就在这一集的开头。
Okay. Meredith has a talking head where she is talking about her wearing a bathing suit to work, and she ends up flashing the camera. Yes, I remember because you made a flash count. Well, there was an alt that I thought was great. Meredith says, I grew up at the beach, and by I grew up, I mean, got drunk and lost my virginity behind a pile of rocks. Oh, my goodness.
好的。梅雷迪思有一个访谈片段，她在里面谈论自己穿着泳衣上班，最后还向镜头闪露了一下。是的，我记得，因为你还专门数了闪露次数。嗯，有一个备选片段我觉得很棒。梅雷迪思说：“我在海滩边长大，我说的长大，是指喝醉了酒，并在乱石堆后面失去了童贞。”哦，天哪。
Meredith isn't the only person who was going to share about having sex at the beach. This was a theme. Ryan had a talking head where he said, great. We're going to the one place I had sex with Kelly outside. And I just know she won't be able to keep her mouth shut. Thanks a lot, Michael. You couldn't take us to the movies? Oh, wait.
梅雷迪思并不是唯一一个分享在海滩发生性关系的人。这是一个主题。瑞安有一个访谈片段，他说：“太棒了。我们要去那个我曾和凯利在户外发生过关系的地方。我敢肯定她肯定管不住自己的嘴。多谢了，迈克尔。你就不能带我们去电影院吗？哦，等等。”
That wouldn't work either. And finally, there was a Phyllis talking head that gave us more insight into her relationship with Bob. Phyllis says, I'm excited to go to the lake. I just hope Michael doesn't make us. swim. Bob doesn't like it when I shave my legs. Oh my god. That beach game's candy bag was so provocative. I know. What was up with the writers that week? Well, I watched the super fan of this episode and there are a lot of fun added tidbits and I wanted to talk about three. Okay. First of all, at the top of the episode, As everyone is talking about getting ready for the beach, you see Kelly and Ryan back in the annex and Kelly is trying to pick a bathing suit.
那也不行。最后，还有一个菲利斯的访谈片段，让我们更深入地了解了她和鲍勃的关系。菲利斯说：“我很兴奋能去湖边。我只是希望迈克尔不要强迫我们游泳。鲍勃不喜欢我刮腿毛。”哦，天哪。那个《海滩游戏》的“糖果袋”内容真是太挑逗了。我知道。那周编剧们是怎么了？嗯，我看了这一集的超级粉丝版，里面增加了很多有趣的额外花絮，我想聊聊其中的三个。好的。首先，在这一集开头，当大家都在谈论准备去海滩时，你可以看到凯利和瑞安在附楼里，凯利正试图挑选一件泳衣。
Okay. So she's sitting on the ground and she's got these two bathing suits in front of her. And I'll let you hear it. Okay. Why is this so crazy hard? Ryan, how do you make decisions? I realize that no matter what decision I make, it won't change the course of anything. And I shouldn't have bothered anyone by saying it out loud.
好的。她坐在地上，面前放着两件泳衣。我让你们听听看。好的。为什么这事儿这么难啊？瑞安，你是怎么做决定的？我意识到无论我做出什么决定，都不会改变任何事情的进程。而且我不应该大声说出来去打扰任何人。
Well, that is so not the case with this, Ryan. This is like the hardest decision I've ever had to make in my whole life. Ryan is so over it. He's like, I tell myself that this makes no difference. All right. And then there was this little bit that was added back to the top of the scene where Michael approaches Pam. You know, this is where he's going to tell her that she has to take diligent note. it's at the beach.
嗯，瑞安，这件事可完全不是这样。这简直是我这辈子必须做的最艰难的决定。瑞安对此感到非常厌烦。他就像是说，我告诉自己这没什么区别。好吧。然后，在场景开头还增加了一小段迈克尔接近帕姆的内容。你知道，这是他要告诉她必须做详细记录的地方。是在海滩上。
Right. Well, this part that they added back gives you a glimpse into her situation with Roy. Oh. Which I thought was kind of cool considering that we know what's going to happen later with, you know. The coal walk. Yeah. So here it is.
对。嗯，他们加回来的这一部分让你瞥见了她和罗伊的情况。哦。考虑到我们知道后来会发生什么，我觉得这挺酷的。走火炭。是的。所以，就是这样。
Pam, you broke up with your boyfriend and then kept working together. How did that work out? You remember you fired Roy for attacking Jim and I don't talk to him anymore, really? Ah, acrimonious. Yeah. She reveals, I don't talk to him anymore. Yeah. Pretty clean break, it sounds like. Yeah. Well, finally, we got a letter from Emily L. who said, in beach games, when they're all sitting down and Michael announces a hot dog eating contest, Phyllis asks for mustard. Michael says, no mustard, just dip it in water so it'll slide down your gullet more easily.
帕姆，你和男朋友分手了，然后还继续一起工作。那是怎么处理的？你记得你因为罗伊袭击吉姆而解雇了他，我真的不再和他说话了？啊，充满怨恨。是的。她透露说，“我不再和他说话了。”是的。听起来是个相当干净利落的了断。是的。好吧，最后，我们收到了一封艾米丽·L的来信，她说：“在《海滩游戏》中，当他们都坐下来，迈克尔宣布要举行热狗大赛时，菲利斯要芥末。迈克尔说，‘不要芥末，把它蘸在水里，这样它更容易滑进你的食道。’”
And no one says anything after this. Phyllis and Angela just look at each other. But in season six, episode 14, the banker, remember, this was our clip show. Toby and the banker are talking and they're talking about all these old scenes and they're replaying them. The hot dog scene replays, Phyllis asks for the mustard, Michael tells her to dip it in water so it'll slide down her gullet more easily. And then everyone says that's what she said and laughs and Michael gets mad. Emily L. said, why are these two scenes different? Well, Angela, you talked about this moment in our breakdown that this was in the deleted scenes.
在这之后没人说话。菲利斯和安吉拉只是互相看了看。但在第六季第14集《银行家》中，记得吗，这是我们的剪辑集。托比和银行家在交谈，他们谈论所有这些旧场景，并且正在重播它们。热狗场景重播了，菲利斯要芥末，迈克尔告诉她蘸水，这样更容易滑进食道。然后每个人都说“那是她说的”，并大笑起来，迈克尔生气了。艾米丽·L问，为什么这两个场景不一样？嗯，安吉拉，你在我们的解析中谈到了这个时刻，说这是在删除片段里的。
this big, that's what she said moment. It has been added back to the Peacock Superfan. In fact, there is so much added back to this hot dog eating contest moment. You get to see the scene of Pam making the hot dogs. You get to see Michael getting so annoyed that people won't eat the hot dogs. It's so much longer. And when I was watching it, it just took me back. I remember shooting it.
这个巨大的“那是她说的”时刻。它已经被加回了孔雀（Peacock）超级粉丝版中。事实上，这个热狗大赛的时刻增加了很多内容。你可以看到帕姆制作热狗的场景。你可以看到迈克尔因为人们不吃热狗而变得非常恼火。它长多了。当我观看它时，它真的把我带回去了。我记得拍摄的时候。
It was so funny. I just love when, like, Michael gets annoyed at us. Yeah. It's, like, such a funny dynamic. It's like father with a bunch of, like, toddlers, like, his energy. That's exactly it. Like, no one wants to put their shoes on. No one wants to put on the hat and it's cold out.
太搞笑了。我就是喜欢迈克尔对我们感到恼火的时候。是的。这是一种非常有趣的动态。就像父亲带着一群蹒跚学步的孩子，那种能量。正是这样。就像，没人想穿鞋。没人想戴帽子，而且外面很冷。
And he's just, like, trying to wrangle a bunch of cats. Yeah, it's definitely if you have Peacock, this is a super fan episode, I think, not to be missed. But finally, Angela, we got this letter that I just had to share from KDS. You're not going to believe this. Here's what Katie said. I just want to say, I do think your podcast is cursed. But it's okay. I will keep listening.
而他就像是在试图赶一群猫。是的，如果你有孔雀（Peacock）平台，这绝对是一集不容错过的超级粉丝版。但最后，安吉拉，我们收到了这封我必须分享的来自KDS的信。你不会相信的。凯蒂是这么说的：“我只想说，我确实认为你们的播客被诅咒了。但没关系。我会继续听的。”
Thankfully, during the bird funeral episode, I did not see any dead birds. Thankfully, because so many people did. And it just keeps going on and on. We're still getting mail about it. I know. But while listening to Beach Games, I was walking on a walking trail. in the woods. And during the part where you mentioned how Leslie had to go to the hospital because Rain accidentally kicked sand in his eye, something, Katie says, either a fly or a large
谢天谢地，在鸟儿葬礼那一集，我没有看到任何死鸟。谢天谢地，因为很多人都看到了。而且这事儿没完没了。我们还在收到关于它的邮件。我知道。但在听《海滩游戏》时，我正走在树林里的一条步道上。在你们提到莱斯利因为雷恩不小心把沙子踢进他眼睛里而不得不去医院的那部分时，有些东西，凯蒂说，要么是一只苍蝇，要么是一大块
piece of dirt flew in my eye. No. Yes. Katie said it was one of those scary times. You could see it coming, but it just happened so fast. You can't do anything. I very thankfully did not have to go to the doctor. I'm unsure if my cornea was scratched, I'm guessing maybe slightly, but was able to heal. I was an absolute searing pain that lasted a couple days. It's gotten much better, but I just thought that was the craziest thing. That is. Can you imagine listening to a story about someone getting something in their eye and then you get something in your eye at that same moment? At the same time? That's so trippy. Well, it's like all these people that, you know, we're talking about birds, you know, dying outside our window, and they look up and a bird is dying outside their window.
脏东西飞进了我的眼睛。不。是的。凯蒂说那是那种可怕的时刻之一。你可以看到它飞过来，但发生得太快了。你什么也做不了。我非常庆幸不必去看医生。我不确定我的角膜是否被划伤了，我猜可能轻微划伤了，但能够自愈。那是一种持续了两天的剧烈疼痛。现在好多了，但我只是觉得那是件最疯狂的事情。确实是。你能想象听着关于某人眼睛进东西的故事，然后你在同一时刻眼睛也进了东西吗？在同一时间？太离奇了。嗯，就像所有这些人，你知道，我们谈论鸟儿在我们窗外死去，他们抬头一看，一只鸟正在他们窗外死去。
What is that? I don't know. Ooh. All right. Well, listen, that's all we got. Please enjoy our breakdown of beach games. Great. And hopefully you won't get anything in your eye.
那是什么？我不知道。噢。好吧，听着，这就是我们所有的内容了。请享受我们对《海滩游戏》的解析。太棒了。希望你的眼睛不会进东西。
Wear some sunglasses. Yeah, while you listen. Good idea, lady. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together. And we're best. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you.
戴上太阳镜。是的，在你听的时候。好主意，女士。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您制作终极《办公室》重温播客。
Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Angela. Hey! We are so excited today, you guys. We're going to the beach today. We're going to play some beach games.
每周，我们将解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个身临其境的人才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。安吉拉。嘿！大家，我们今天太兴奋了。我们今天要出发去海滩。我们要玩一些海滩游戏。
Yes. Season 3, episode 22, written by Jen Salata and Greg Daniels, directed by Harold Ramos. It's Beach Games. We have so much to talk about. I kind of feel like we just got to get to it. We should dive in because I took very diligent notes. And I think you did in real life.
是的。第三季第22集，由简·萨拉塔和格雷格·丹尼尔斯编剧，哈罗德·雷米斯执导。这就是《海滩游戏》。我们要聊的太多了。我感觉我们得赶紧开始了。我们应该深入探讨，因为我做了非常详尽的笔记。而且我觉得你在现实生活中也做了。
We'll get to that. All right, here's a summary. Michael is invited to interview for a job opening at Corporate. Certain that he's a lock for the job, he takes his employees to the beach at Lake Scranton and holds a series of challenges to determine his successor. At the end of the day, Michael sets up a coal walk as a final challenge. Pam does the coal walk and summons up the courage to tell Jim and the whole office her real feelings.
我们会谈到那个的。好吧，这是一个总结。迈克尔受邀参加公司的一个职位面试。他确信自己稳拿这份工作，于是带着员工去斯克兰顿湖的海滩，并举行了一系列挑战来确定他的继任者。在一天结束时，迈克尔安排了一场走火炭作为最终挑战。帕姆完成了走火炭，并鼓起勇气告诉吉姆和整个办公室她的真实感受。
Oh, man. That was so tough to watch. It was beautiful, Jenna. Pam broke my heart in this episode. Yeah, I had not seen this episode since it aired. and I, it shocked me. And I did it and I was still shocked. Isn't that funny?
天哪。看那一幕真是太难受了。那很美，珍娜。帕姆在这一集里伤透了我的心。是的，自从这一集播出后我就没再看过。它震惊了我。我演了它，但我仍然感到震惊。这不是很滑稽吗？
Like the way the brain works where you're like, wait, I did all that. That's crazy. That's kind of cool. Yeah. So fast fact number one, Angela, our beach games is set on Lake Scranton. Yeah, obviously we didn't go to the real Lake Scranton, but I did want to just talk a little bit about it. Oh, let's hear it. Well, Lake Scranton is actually a reservoir, and it was built with a dam in the early 1900s.
就像大脑运作的方式，你会想，等等，这一切都是我做的？太疯狂了。这挺酷的。是的。所以，第一个快速事实，安吉拉，我们的《海滩游戏》设定在斯克兰顿湖。是的，显然我们没有去真正的斯克兰顿湖，但我确实想聊聊它。哦，说来听听。嗯，斯克兰顿湖实际上是一个水库，它是20世纪初用大坝建造的。
The dam was built by William Walker Scranton, and the body of water it created was originally called the Burnt Bridge Reservoir, although the public calls it Lake Scranton. Well, Jenna, you and I have both been to Scranton, and one of the times that I went, they drove me around Lake Scranton, and it is so pretty. So pretty. there is a running track around the Real Lakes Granton. And it's absolutely gorgeous, but I did look up a few facts about it, Ange. Yeah? Swimming is not permitted. Boating is not permitted, but canoeing and kayaking is allowed.
大坝是由威廉·沃克·斯克兰顿建造的，它形成的水体最初被称为“烧桥水库”，尽管公众称它为斯克兰顿湖。嗯，珍娜，你我都去过斯克兰顿，有一次我去的时候，他们开车带我绕着斯克兰顿湖转了一圈，它真的很美。非常美。真正的斯克兰顿湖周围有一条跑道。它绝对华丽，但我确实查了一些关于它的事实，安吉。是吗？禁止游泳。禁止划船，但允许划独木舟和皮划艇。
I wonder why you can't swim in it. Like, I get the no motor, right? That's like, I think that's sort of really cool. But I wonder why the no swimming. I don't know. Hmm. I'm not sure. We're intrigued.
我想知道为什么不能在里面游泳。就像，我明白禁止机动船，对吧？我觉得那挺酷的。但我不知道为什么禁止游泳。我不知道。嗯。我不确定。我们很好奇。
Scranton, write us. Tell us why you can't swim in your lake. Well, this leads me to fast fact number two. I brought up all these facts about Lake Scranton because we had a fan question from Sophia B., Aaron W., Dana D., Marin B, and Faye B. Where was the beach that you filmed this episode? Was it a long commute and how many days did you film at that location?
斯克兰顿，写信给我们。告诉我们为什么你们的湖不能游泳。嗯，这引出了第二个快速事实。我提到了所有关于斯克兰顿湖的事实，因为我们收到了索菲亚·B、亚伦·W、达纳·D、马林·B和费伊·B的粉丝提问。你们拍摄这一集的海滩在哪里？通勤时间长吗？你们在那个地点拍摄了几天？
Well, I will tell you, tell us. I know, I remember one or two things, but I bet you got all the details, so let's hear it. Well, I reached out to Kentapedia and here's what he told me. We filmed at the beach at the Hanson Dam Recreation Center in Silmar. We shot there for four days and nights. Will you mention that you've been to the real Lake Scranton? I've been to this real Hanson Dam Recreation Center outside of us filming. You have? Yes, because there is this museum, this children's museum, called the Discovery Cube that's right nearby. And when you go through this area, there's also like an equestrian center. There's an aquatic center.
嗯，我会告诉你们，告诉我们。我知道，我记得一两件事，但我敢打赌你掌握了所有细节，所以说来听听。嗯，我联系了肯塔百科（Kentapedia），这是他告诉我的。我们在希尔马的汉森大坝娱乐中心的海滩拍摄。我们在那里拍摄了四个昼夜。你会提到你去过真正的斯克兰顿湖吗？我在拍摄之外去过这个真正的汉森大坝娱乐中心。你去过？是的，因为附近有一个博物馆，一个儿童博物馆，叫“发现立方体”。当你经过这个区域时，还有一个马术中心。有一个水上中心。
There's a playground. Because, lady, the place that they put us to film this episode was like, I had no idea all this stuff was there. My memory of where we filmed was it was like a. chemical pond runoff, like, from a dam where I was like, are we, like, breathing in fumes? It was really, like, gross. They, maybe, like, the only place they let you film is in this, like, weird jinky corner of this. Where this area.
有一个游乐场。因为，女士，他们让我们拍摄这一集的地方，我根本不知道那里有所有这些东西。我对我们拍摄地点的记忆是，它就像一个化学池塘径流，来自大坝，当时我在想，我们是在吸入烟雾吗？它真的很恶心。他们，也许，他们唯一让你拍摄的地方就是在这个奇怪的、破烂的角落里。在这个区域。
Where the runoff water goes. Yeah, because this recreation center is actually really nice. But here's something I found out, too. The lake where we filmed is filled with circulated drinking water. What? Yeah, circulated drinking water, and it offers fishing and public boating. Oh, my gosh. So when Ed is out there floating in the water, he was in some recycled drinking water.
径流水去的地方。是的，因为这个娱乐中心其实真的很不错。但这是我发现的另一件事。我们拍摄的湖里装的是循环饮用水。什么？是的，循环饮用水，它提供钓鱼和公共划船。哦，天哪。所以当埃德漂在水里时，他是在一些循环饮用水里。
Oh, well, that's good to know. All these years, I worried for him that he was going to get like some kind of weird rash. All right, well, let's move on to fastback number three. Three. So like we said earlier, this was written by both Greg Daniels and Jen Salada. And we reached out to Jen Salada and she sent us audio clips. She sent us so many. She's so gracious. We're going to sprinkle them throughout. But here she has one for us right now. Yes, she is going to tell us a little bit about the inspiration for this episode and what it was like to write a script with Greg. I think the inspiration for this episode was just Survivor. I think it was Greg's idea. And I remember all of us talking about Survivor being a perfect way for Michael Scott to pick his successor.
哦，好吧，那很高兴知道。这些年来，我一直担心他会得某种奇怪的皮疹。好吧，让我们继续第三个快速事实。三。所以就像我们之前说的，这是由格雷格·丹尼尔斯和简·萨拉塔共同编剧的。我们联系了简·萨拉塔，她给我们发了音频片段。她发了好多。她太亲切了。我们将把它们穿插在整个节目中。但她现在就有一个片段要给我们。是的，她要告诉我们一点关于这一集的灵感，以及和格雷格一起写剧本是什么感觉。我想这一集的灵感就是《幸存者》。我想那是格雷格的主意。我记得我们所有人都谈论《幸存者》是迈克尔·斯科特挑选继任者的完美方式。
I mean, what other way would this man use to try to pick somebody who could run a branch? It just seemed like a no-brainer for Michael Scott to do it this way. And then we tried to sit down and write the whole thing together. and we were like, this isn't going to work. So we divided it up. We can't remember exactly how we did it. I think sometimes with Paul, when I'd write a script with Paul, I'd do the first half, he'd do the second or vice versa.
我是说，这个男人还会用什么其他方式来挑选能管理分部的人呢？对迈克尔·斯科特来说，用这种方式做这件事简直是不言而喻的。然后我们试着坐下来一起写整个剧本。我们当时想，这行不通。所以我们把它分开了。我们记不清具体是怎么做的了。我想有时和保罗一起，当我写剧本时，我会写前半部分，他写后半部分，反之亦然。
And with Greg, I think we didn't do cleanly divide it up that way. I think just he did some of the scenes. I did others. And I do remember that the Pam speech was mostly Greg. And I think that is such a beautiful part of the episode. and the Pam arc pre-existed the idea of the Beach Games episode. So I think some of the ideas from that speech were in his notes. But I love that part.
和格雷格一起，我想我们没有那么清晰地分开。我想只是他写了一些场景，我写了其他的。我确实记得帕姆的演讲主要是格雷格写的。我认为那是这一集中非常美丽的一部分。而且帕姆的弧线在《海滩游戏》这一集构思之前就存在了。所以我认为那个演讲中的一些想法在他的笔记里。但我喜欢那部分。
It is one of my favorite parts, if not my favorite part of the episode. So credit to Greg for that part for sure. But we both wrote a bunch of it. I just don't think we clearly divided it up. Well, Ange, I remember Greg talking to me about this Pam arc of her final her voice. Yeah. And he planted this idea a few episodes ago, and we sprinkled it in.
这是我最喜欢的部分之一，如果不是我最喜欢的一集部分的话。所以那部分绝对要归功于格雷格。但我们都写了很多。我只是不认为我们清晰地分开了。嗯，安吉，我记得格雷格和我谈过帕姆这个最终表达心声的弧线。是的。他在几集前就埋下了这个想法，我们把它穿插进去了。
And so I just love this idea that he'd been maybe writing down little notes about what Pam will finally say when she says something. And I remember getting the script for this episode and just being so excited as an actor. There was just so much to chew on. I mean, I thought that it was just beautifully done. really just Pam's whole journey this season about even her sending the wrong beer back. You know what I mean? Yeah. And just having these moments where she stood up for herself and spoke her truth. And it all builds to this one moment. And it's just so well done. When I was rewatching this, I was marveling at what a well-written episode this was.
所以我很喜欢这个想法，他可能一直在写关于帕姆最终说出心声时会说什么的小笔记。我记得收到这一集的剧本时，作为演员我感到非常兴奋。有太多值得咀嚼的东西了。我是说，我觉得它完成得非常漂亮。真的只是帕姆这一季的整个旅程，关于她甚至退回错误的啤酒。你知道我的意思吗？是的。并且有这些她为自己挺身而出并说出真相的时刻。这一切都汇聚到了这一个时刻。而且它完成得太好了。当我重温这一集时，我惊叹于这是一集写得多么好的剧集。
Yes. Well, maybe we should take a quick break and then come. come back and break down this episode. I can't wait. Jenna, we have so much to talk about. I know. We've been trading a lot of texts about this one. All right. So this episode starts with this very funny cold open.
是的。嗯，也许我们应该快速休息一下，然后回来解析这一集。我等不及了。珍娜，我们要聊的太多了。我知道。我们关于这一集交换了很多短信。好吧。所以这一集以这个非常有趣的冷开场开始。
It is Dwight and Michael. They're in Michael's office. And Michael's convinced that he's sick, you guys. He's convinced they're scrolling through a website. It's like WebMD or something, trying to figure out what he is sick from. Dwight's very concerned. Yes. Pam has a talking head where she explains that this happens about 40 times a year.
是德怀特和迈克尔。他们在迈克尔的办公室。迈克尔确信自己病了，伙计们。他确信他们正在浏览一个网站。就像WebMD之类的，试图弄清楚他得了什么病。德怀特非常担心。是的。帕姆有一个访谈片段，解释说这种情况一年大约发生40次。
Michael, it's sick that has no symptoms. Yes. Well, Jen left us a really great audio clip about this, about the inspiration for this cold open. Sam, can you play that? Greg and I wrote the episode together, and it was really fun. I remember being really curious, what is Greg's process going to be like? because writing scripts, it was such a solitary part of what we did. And so I was always wondering, like, what are other writers like when they go off to write a script?
迈克尔，那是没有症状的病。是的。嗯，简给我们留下了一个关于这个的非常棒的音频片段，关于这个冷开场的灵感。萨姆，你能播放那个吗？格雷格和我一起写了这一集，真的很有趣。我记得当时很好奇，格雷格的创作过程会是什么样的？因为写剧本，是我们所做工作中非常孤独的一部分。所以我总是想，其他编剧在去写剧本时是什么样的？
It became quickly obvious that his process at the beginning was like mine, which is like every other writer I've ever met, which is there's a fair amount of procrastinating right away before you have to get into the hard work. It's figuring out what you want to eat. It's sharpening your pencils. It's figuring out the temperature of the room. And for both of us, we started focusing. focusing on ailments, like what was wrong, how we weren't feeling well, like my ear was
很快就很明显，他开始时的过程和我一样，就像我见过的其他所有编剧一样，那就是在开始艰苦工作之前，会有一段相当长的拖延时间。是决定想吃什么。是削铅笔。是弄清楚房间的温度。我们俩都开始专注于疾病，比如哪里不对劲，我们感觉如何，比如我的耳朵
bothering him and he wasn't feeling super well at the time. And so we went on WebMD and we tried to diagnose ourselves and each other. And they used to have a little body where you could like point to the part of the body that hurt and that was bothering you. And so he diagnosed me with an ear infection or at least inner ear congestion. And he ended up putting some oil from the kitchen that we found in my ear. It turns out you can do this. It is a home remedy. And it helped.
困扰着他，而且他当时感觉不太好。所以我们上了WebMD，试图诊断我们自己和对方。他们过去有一个小身体模型，你可以指向疼痛的身体部位，那困扰着你。所以他诊断我患有耳部感染，或者至少是内耳充血。他最后从厨房里找了一些油滴进我的耳朵里。事实证明你可以这样做。这是一种家庭疗法。而且它有帮助。
It helped my ear. And I think we diagnosed him with walking pneumonia. So we did this right when we were sent off to write the Beach Games episode. And it ended up becoming our cold open because we were probably looking for a cold open and we're like, what about what we're doing right now? There is so much about that audio clip that I love. It's so relatable. It's like whenever you sit down to do something, and it doesn't matter what it is. I mean, theirs was this writing assignment, but all the different ways you procrastinate
它对我的耳朵有帮助。我想我们诊断他患有游走性肺炎。所以我们在被派去写《海滩游戏》这一集时做了这件事。它最终成了我们的冷开场，因为我们可能正在寻找一个冷开场，我们想，我们现在正在做的事情怎么样？关于那个音频片段，有很多我喜欢的地方。它太容易引起共鸣了。就像无论你什么时候坐下来做某事，不管是什么。我是说，他们的是这个写作任务，但你拖延的所有不同方式
before you get to that thing. Yes. Well, Angela, you and I are working on a project that we can't say exactly what it is, but it involves quite a bit of writing. And I, every time I sit down to write, I will write one sentence. and then I will get up and get a snack. And then I'll come back and write a sentence and then I'll be like, I need more coffee.
在你开始做那件事之前。是的。嗯，安吉拉，你和我正在做一个项目，我们不能确切地说是什么，但它涉及相当多的写作。而且我，每次我坐下来写作，我都会写一句话。然后我会站起来吃点零食。然后我会回来写一句话，然后我会想，我需要更多咖啡。
It's like the procrastination. I loved that she shared that because I think my perception is always that creativity comes easy to people who are successful. I always think like it must pour out of them. And it is such a slog. So I loved hearing that. But then the other thing I loved was that their procrastination
就像拖延症。我喜欢她分享这一点，因为我认为我的看法总是认为创造力对成功的人来说很容易。我总是认为它一定是从他们身上涌出来的。但这真是一项苦差事。所以我喜欢听到这一点。但后来我喜欢的另一件事是他们的拖延症
it got turned into a story idea. Like, it's worth it. Like, all of that nonsense, it produced something. Right. Well, I had a writing professor in college that used to always say, write what you know. Write what you know, and it will be honest. Oh, well, I just loved this opening. And, you know, before they can really diagnose Michael, Pam walks in the office and says,
它变成了一个故事创意。就像，这是值得的。就像，所有那些废话，它产生了一些东西。对。嗯，我在大学里有一位写作教授，他总是说，写你所知道的。写你所知道的，它会是诚实的。哦，好吧，我只是喜欢这个开场。而且，在他们真正能诊断出迈克尔之前，帕姆走进办公室说，
David Wallace is on the phone. Yeah. It's very clear that David Wallace does not call very often. No, it's a big deal. Well, Michael gets on the phone with him. Oh, my goodness. Michael, what are you doing? Michael, the way Michael talks to his bosses are even when he goes to New York to corporate, there is such a casualness to how he relates to them that is so not work appropriate. It's so true. Well, we find out the reason that David Wallace is calling is because there is a job opening at corporate and he would like Michael to apply. I can't believe he still wants Michael to apply after this phone call, but I think Michael has a very, very good sales record and a good record of connecting with people out in the sales world. Yeah, he's a really good salesman. Here's a little interesting tidbit, Jenna. there was a scene that was deleted right after this phone call of David Wallace and Michael,
大卫·华莱士在电话上。是的。很明显大卫·华莱士不经常打电话。不，这是一件大事。嗯，迈克尔接了他的电话。哦，天哪。迈克尔，你在做什么？迈克尔，迈克尔和老板说话的方式，即使当他去纽约公司总部时，他与他们相处的方式有一种随意感，这太不适合工作场合了。太真实了。嗯，我们发现大卫·华莱士打电话的原因是因为公司有一个职位空缺，他想让迈克尔申请。我不敢相信他在这个电话之后还想让迈克尔申请，但我认为迈克尔有非常、非常好的销售记录，并且在销售领域与人建立联系方面有很好的记录。是的，他是一个非常好的推销员。这是一个有趣的小花絮，珍娜。在大卫·华莱士和迈克尔的这个电话之后，有一个被删除的场景，
David Wallace calls Jim and tells Jim the same thing. I saw that in the script. And they chose not to use it. They chose to like reveal it later that it's Jim calling. It's Jim being more proactive in his life. But there was a version where David calls Jim. Yeah. I noticed that in the script because that scene on the beach with Jim and Karen calling David,
大卫·华莱士给吉姆打电话，告诉吉姆同样的事情。我在剧本里看到了。他们选择不使用它。他们选择像后来揭示的那样，是吉姆打电话。是吉姆在生活中更主动。但有一个版本是大卫给吉姆打电话。是的。我在剧本里注意到了这一点，因为海滩上吉姆和凯伦给大卫打电话的那个场景，
and kind of asking if they could go for the job as well, that was not in the original script. So that must have been something that they added later. Well, I remember when we were at the beach, there were a few scenes that sort of happened on the fly. They were like kind of pitched in the moment. And that was one of them. Yeah. So now it is beach day. And at two minutes, 28 seconds, you get a fantastic look at Michael's outfit.
并且有点询问他们是否也可以去争取那个职位，那不在原始剧本中。所以那一定是他们后来添加的东西。嗯，我记得我们在海滩时，有几个场景是临时发生的。它们就像是在那一刻即兴提出的。而那是其中之一。是的。所以现在是海滩日。在两分28秒，你可以很好地看到迈克尔的装束。
He clearly bought everything he could at sandals in the, gift shop. He's got a t-shirt. He's got a hat. He has a necklace that he probably bought their little pucashell necklace. He's really ready. And he tells everyone they better go potty before they leave. I'm just like, Michael's so ready to be a dad. You know, he just is. Bless his heart. And you get to see everybody in casual attire. And I just loved it. Well, I noticed something about our wardrobe. What's that? Do you see how much? many layers we all have on. Oh, well, that was for a reason. Yep. It was because we shot this episode in March, and we knew that that location was going to be perfectly warm and lovely during the
他显然在礼品店买了所有他能买的东西。他有一件T恤。他有一顶帽子。他有一条项链，他可能买了他们的小贝壳项链。他真的准备好了。他告诉大家在离开前最好去上个厕所。我只是觉得，迈克尔太准备好当爸爸了。你知道，他就是。保佑他的心。你可以看到每个人都穿着休闲装。我只是喜欢它。嗯，我注意到了关于我们服装的一件事。那是什么？你看到我们都穿了多少层了吗？哦，嗯，那是有原因的。是的。这是因为我们在三月拍摄了这一集，我们知道那个地点在白天会非常温暖可爱。
day. It turned out to be hot as F. There was a heat wave. There was this crazy freak March heat wave. It was 98 degrees. I wrote in my journal that it was 98 degrees our first day. Yeah. But then when the sun went down, it was freezing cold. Yeah, we're in this valley. So it was like these really huge swings of temperature. Yeah. So wardrobe tried to give us layers to help take us between these two extreme temperatures. And I noticed when I was looking at everyone's beach attire.
结果热得要命。有一场热浪。有一场疯狂的三月热浪。有98华氏度。我在日记里写道，我们第一天有98华氏度。是的。但当太阳下山时，冷得要命。是的，我们在山谷里。所以温度波动非常大。是的。所以服装组试图给我们提供层叠的衣服，以帮助我们在两个极端温度之间过渡。当我看着每个人的海滩装束时，我注意到了。
They're layers. Well, you know what I noticed? This is really, really fun to me. Toby and Angela almost have on the same outfit. What? I did not notice that. They're both wearing these beige tops. They have huge beige floppy hats and like sort of like just like pants on. But like and they're also both obsessed with sunscreen. Both of them. Well, I noticed that both Andy and Stanley are wearing a red polo shirt. Oh. Yeah. I did not catch that. But guess what I did catch. And I know it's your favorite moment of the day. Is it a new plant at reception? Because we. need a sting for this new plant alert three minutes 32 seconds it is a red flowering plant there are big red flowers on this plant okay i'm sorry i see that as a metaphor because pam is going to bloom in
它们是层叠的。嗯，你知道我注意到了什么吗？这对我来说真的、真的很有趣。托比和安吉拉几乎穿着同样的衣服。什么？我没注意到。他们都穿着米色的上衣。他们有巨大的米色软帽，还有像裤子一样的东西。但是，而且他们也都沉迷于防晒霜。他们两个。嗯，我注意到安迪和斯坦利都穿着红色的Polo衫。哦。是的。我没捕捉到那个。但猜猜我捕捉到了什么。我知道这是你一天中最喜欢的时刻。是接待处的新植物吗？因为我们需要为这个新植物警报设置一个提示音，三分钟32秒，那是一株红色开花植物，这株植物上有大红花，好吧，抱歉，我把它看作一个隐喻，因为帕姆要在这一集中绽放
this episode that is so good pam's going to flower she's going to bloom well we forgot to talk about how michael has told toby he can't come on the beach day oh that was so good Toby's disappointment. He doesn't get to see you in a two-piece. Jenna, I wrote, how did you get through that scene without laughing? How did you do it? Because when you were like, oh, thanks, I'm going to wear my two-piece. His face is so good. It's so funny. We also didn't mention, and I'm tracking this, the Meredith flash count. This is flash number two. Yes. Meredith has that great talking head where she explains that she wore her bathing suit to work. And she lifts her shirt. to show you, and she's like, oh, shoot, it's in my purse. Michael has a special assignment for Pam on Beach Day. Of course, because she needs an assignment. Yeah, Michael tells her that she has to take notes all day on people's character, humor, charisma, and the indefinable qualities that they possess, but not their hotness
这太好了，帕姆要开花了，她要绽放了。嗯，我们忘了谈迈克尔告诉托比他不能参加海滩日的事了。哦，那太好了。托比的失望。他没能看到你穿两件套。珍娜，我写道，你是怎么在不笑的情况下演完那个场景的？你是怎么做到的？因为当你像说，“哦，谢谢，我要穿我的两件套”时。他的脸太棒了。太搞笑了。我们也没提到，而且我正在追踪这个，梅雷迪思的闪露次数。这是第二次闪露。是的。梅雷迪思有一个很棒的访谈片段，解释说她穿了泳衣上班。她掀起衬衫向你展示，她说，“哦，糟了，它在我的钱包里。”迈克尔给帕姆在海滩日有一个特别任务。当然，因为她需要一个任务。是的，迈克尔告诉她，她必须整天记录人们的性格、幽默感、魅力，以及他们拥有的难以定义的品质，但不是他们的性感程度
per se. I loved that line. Yeah. Per se. Like, she could add that if she. She wanted, but it's not 100% necessary, I guess. But he also doesn't tell her why she has to do this. No, he just needs to find out which of his employees has the skills to be a chicken with a head.
本身。我喜欢那句台词。是的。本身。就像，如果她想，她可以加上那个，但我想这不是100%必要的。但他也没告诉她为什么要这样做。不，他只是需要找出他的员工中谁有能力成为领头羊。
That's right. That makes sense. What? Yeah. Well, let's see. Now the gang is all going to board the bus. Michael's got a big party bus to take everyone to the beach. Yeah, Crete's got a boogie board.
没错。那说得通。什么？是的。嗯，让我们看看。现在大家都要上车了。迈克尔有一辆大派对巴士带大家去海滩。是的，克里特有一个趴板。
He's ready to go. Yeah, Kevin says he just wants to lay on the beach and eat hot dogs. It's literally all he's ever wanted. Now, this bus that we're all riding in, we really rode in that. That's how we got to the beach. That day, but then the days after that, we drove ourselves. Yes, that first day, though, they shuttled us from the stages, and the plan was that we would use the time to shoot the scene with Michael. But then we had extra time.
他准备好出发了。是的，凯文说他只想躺在海滩上吃热狗。这简直是他一直以来想要的全部。现在，我们乘坐的这辆巴士，我们真的坐了那辆。那就是我们去海滩的方式。那天，但之后的那几天，我们自己开车。是的，不过第一天，他们用班车把我们从摄影棚送过去，计划是我们利用这段时间拍摄迈克尔的场景。但后来我们有了额外的时间。
Yeah. So we all started singing. Well, listen, I watched the DVD commentary for this, and I thought it was so sweet because Harold Ramos is on the DVD commentary. And Jen Salada was on it as well. And Jen was like, you know, Harold said, I'd never been on a bus where we didn't sing. Yes. He was like, everybody, when you get on a bus with people, you sing, right? That was Harold Ramos, being genius.
是的。所以我们都开始唱歌了。嗯，听着，我看了这一集的DVD评论，我觉得它太甜了，因为哈罗德·雷米斯在DVD评论里。简·萨拉塔也在里面。简说，你知道，哈罗德说，“我从来没坐过一辆我们不唱歌的巴士。”是的。他就像是，每个人，当你和人们一起上巴士时，你会唱歌，对吧？那是哈罗德·雷米斯，天才。
And I do know two other songs we sang, Jenna. Do you remember? What? We sang Tiny Dancer. Oh, yes. And then we also sang Friends, and we did the handclaps. I remember that. Yeah.
而且我确实知道我们唱的其他两首歌，珍娜。你记得吗？什么？我们唱了《Tiny Dancer》。哦，是的。然后我们还唱了《Friends》，我们拍了手。我记得那个。是的。
I didn't know all the words to that, so I just clapped. Well, Angela, I have to say, I remember that vibe of us just singing our way to the beach that very first day. And then, frankly, as we walked off the bus and got hit in the face with that 98-degree weather, I feel like you see that play out on our faces. I felt the same thing in rewatching this. That shot when we're walking across the beach, we're all carrying our stuff. Meredith is dragging a cooler. Do you know the shot I'm talking about?
我不知道那首歌的所有歌词，所以我只是拍手。嗯，安吉拉，我不得不说，我记得第一天我们唱歌去海滩的那种氛围。然后，坦率地说，当我们走下巴士，被那98度的天气迎面击中时，我觉得你在我们的脸上看到了那种表现。我在重温这一集时也有同样的感觉。那个我们走过海滩的镜头，我们都带着我们的东西。梅雷迪思拖着一个冷藏箱。你知道我在说哪个镜头吗？
I took a photo of it because I think it's so amazing. I took a screen grab. That is all real. That struggled to drag that stuff across the beach and it was hot. You guys have all been there. You've been to that beach where you have. to park super far away and lug your stuff in the heat and all your enthusiasm of getting there is so quickly like, oh, God, here we go. Well, Angela, you mentioned a little bit about the challenges
我拍了一张照片，因为我觉得它太棒了。我截了一张图。那都是真实的。那种拖着东西穿过海滩的挣扎，而且很热。你们都去过那里。你去过那个海滩，你必须把车停在超级远的地方，然后在炎热中拖着你的东西，你到达那里的所有热情都很快变成了，哦，天哪，我们开始吧。嗯，安吉拉，你提到了关于这个地点的挑战
of this location and Jen talked about that as well. So Sam, will you play that audio clip number eight? It was a super fun episode, but it was really challenging. I remember even the bathrooms weren't close to the location. So, and there was as close as they could be, but we needed a golf car. And so anytime anybody had to go to the bathroom, there was a golf cart taking people up a hill. And I remember it was super hot and super cold all within the course of one day. There were heat lamps and heat warmers. And then it was really, really hot in the middle of the afternoon. So everything about this episode was a challenge.
简也谈到了这一点。所以萨姆，你能播放那个音频片段八吗？这是一集超级有趣的剧集，但真的很有挑战性。我记得甚至厕所离拍摄地点都不近。所以，而且那是他们能做到的最近距离，但我们需要一辆高尔夫球车。所以任何时候有人需要去厕所，都会有一辆高尔夫球车带人上山。我记得那一天之内又超级热又超级冷。有热灯和加热器。然后下午中间又真的、真的非常热。所以这一集的一切都是挑战。
And I feel like we just, in order to get everything great, it just took a long time. Oh, yeah, it was slim pickens out there on the beach. I mean, we had just enough room to shoot. there was, I mean, I remember us just being huddled under like a little pop-up tent or something. Yeah, I mean, when I was looking at the photos that I have, there's nothing out there. Once we were on the beach, we're sort of on our own because things couldn't be in the shot. They did get us like some lawn chairs. I have this great photo, Jenna, of Steve and I sitting next to each other, clearly between a scene.
我觉得我们只是，为了让一切都变得很棒，它确实花了很多时间。哦，是的，海滩上没什么好东西。我是说，我们只有足够的空间拍摄。那里，我是说，我记得我们只是挤在一个小弹出式帐篷之类的东西下面。是的，我是说，当我看着我有的照片时，外面什么都没有。一旦我们在海滩上，我们基本上是靠自己，因为东西不能出现在镜头里。他们确实给我们弄了一些草坪椅。我有一张很棒的照片，珍娜，我和史蒂夫坐在一起，显然是在两个场景之间。
And we're just like in lawn chairs, like just hanging out and talking. I just love it. And also this week, Jenna, I brought my football. Like in real life, I had it in my car. And when they would have some setups to do, in particular, like when they were setting up the hot dogs and all that, I have these photos of us throwing the football on the beach. We were having our own beach day. So yes, it was sort of like there weren't bathrooms nearby and it was hot, but we were also just making our own fun. And we always did that.
我们就像在草坪椅上，只是闲逛和聊天。我就是喜欢它。而且这一周，珍娜，我带了我的足球。就像在现实生活中，它在我的车里。当他们需要做一些设置时，特别是在他们设置热狗等等的时候，我有这些我们在海滩上扔足球的照片。我们在过我们自己的海滩日。所以是的，它有点像附近没有厕所，而且很热，但我们也只是在自娱自乐。我们总是那样做。
I felt like as a group, Jenna, we were really just kind of roll with it and make the best of it. And I always love that about our show. All right. Well, let's see. Where are we? We've arrived. We're ganking our stuff down the beach. And Michael tells us it's time to start the fun tivities. Such a great word. I want to use it. It's like nifty gifties. Funivities. Can you imagine if I did that like at a family reunion? All right, everybody, it's time for funtivities. I love it. I know. You and I would both be excited. We'd want to be on the funtivities, like, organizing group.
我觉得作为一个团队，珍娜，我们真的只是顺其自然，并充分利用它。我一直喜欢我们节目的这一点。好吧。嗯，让我们看看。我们在哪里？我们到了。我们把东西拖到海滩上。迈克尔告诉我们是时候开始“趣味活动”了。这么棒的词。我想用它。就像“精巧礼物”。趣味活动。你能想象如果我在家庭聚会上那样做吗？好吧，大家，是时候进行趣味活动了。我喜欢它。我知道。你我都会很兴奋。我们会想参加趣味活动，就像，组织小组。
The funtivities committee. The funivities committee. Or the committee to plan funivities. Or what was wrong with my brain? The funtivities organizing group. What? Mama needs another cup of tea. Well, Michael tells everyone that they have to divide into teams.
趣味活动委员会。趣味活动委员会。或者计划趣味活动的委员会。或者我的大脑怎么了？趣味活动组织小组。什么？妈妈需要再来一杯茶。嗯，迈克尔告诉大家他们必须分成小组。
He picks the team leaders, quote unquote, randomly. They are Jim, Dwight, Andy, and Stanley. These guys are clearly his top contenders for the job. And he makes them choose their tribes. Yes. But not Pam. Pam cannot be included. Pam can't be included in.
他随机挑选了团队领导，引用，引用。他们是吉姆、德怀特、安迪和斯坦利。这些人显然是他职位的头号竞争者。他让他们选择他们的部落。是的。但帕姆不行。帕姆不能被包括在内。帕姆不能被包括在内。
And also, these are the team names. Ready? Yes. We have Gryffindor, Voldemort, Blue, and USA. It's incredible. Yes. Well, I loved all of them. these Harry Potter references, you know, my son is right in that age range where we've got
而且，这些是团队名称。准备好了吗？是的。我们有格兰芬多、伏地魔、蓝色和美国。太不可思议了。是的。嗯，我喜欢他们所有人。这些哈利·波特参考，你知道，我儿子正处于那个年龄段，我们有
Harry Potter over here. And we reached out to Jen about this. What was up with the Harry Potter thing? Yeah, I was so curious. I was like, was this like an inside joke in the writer's room? And this is what Jen had to say. We had a bunch of Harry Potter fans in the writer's room. It even evolved to a situation where we had chopsticks hanging around the room from takeout, you know, because we ate a lot of our meals in the writer's room. And so one afternoon, we decorated our chopsticks while we were probably pitching stories and jokes. We each decorated chopsticks. And then we had, we were pretending that they were Harry Potter wands, and we would do spells on each other, probably just comedy spells. But we even had wands
哈利·波特在这里。我们联系了简关于这件事。哈利·波特是怎么回事？是的，我太好奇了。我当时想，这是编剧室里的内部笑话吗？这就是简要说的。我们的编剧室里有一群哈利·波特迷。它甚至演变成一种情况，我们的房间里到处都是外卖剩下的筷子，你知道，因为我们在编剧室里吃了很多饭。所以一天下午，当我们可能在推销故事和笑话时，我们装饰了我们的筷子。我们每个人都装饰了筷子。然后我们有，我们假装它们是哈利·波特魔杖，我们会对彼此施咒，可能只是喜剧咒语。但我们甚至有魔杖
near the writer's room door that were just little thumbtacks, you know, spread apart so that we would rest our wands on them. So everybody had their Harry Potter chopstick wands and our wands and that sounds super dorky. And I believe it is. It was really fun. Once again, what the writers were doing to procrastinate made it into a script. Yeah, I feel like there's probably more of that than we will ever know. Yes, exactly. All right. So at seven minutes, six seconds, Michael has his big Survivor speech. Now, you guys, we've shared this before, but our camera operators, Randall and Matt, both worked on Survivor. So this had been a little bit of an interesting callback for them, right, Jenna?
在编剧室门边，我们放了一些小图钉，你知道，把它们隔开，这样我们就可以把魔杖靠在上面。所以每个人都有他们的哈利·波特筷子魔杖，还有我们自己的魔杖，这听起来超级书呆子气。我相信确实如此。这真的很有趣。再一次，编剧们为了拖延时间所做的事情被写进了剧本里。是的，我觉得这种事可能比我们知道的还要多。是的，没错。好了。在7分06秒，迈克尔发表了他那段伟大的《幸存者》演讲。现在，伙计们，我们之前分享过，但我们的摄像师兰德尔和马特都曾参与过《幸存者》的制作。所以这对他们来说是一个有趣的呼应，对吧，珍娜？
Well, yes. And how prepared were they to lug cameras on their shoulders on a beach? I mean, these guys, they were like, oh, I've come full circle. Yeah, bring it. So Michael, says this. A group of Americans will undergo the ultimate challenge. One day, 14 strangers who work together, but only one survivor. And they're all like, what? What's about to happen here? Well, what's about to happen is a spoon and egg race, Angela. Oh, yeah. Except the person with the egg will be blindfolded. Also, Jenna, I don't know if you remember this, but poor Brian, they had him in the background. He's just eating his egg.
嗯，是的。他们有多大的准备去扛着摄像机在沙滩上走？我是说，这些家伙，他们就像是，哦，我兜了一圈又回来了。是的，来吧。所以迈克尔说了这段话。一群美国人将接受终极挑战。一天，14个一起工作的陌生人，但只有一个幸存者。他们都像是，什么？这里要发生什么？嗯，要发生的是勺子和鸡蛋赛跑，安吉拉。哦，是的。除了拿鸡蛋的人会被蒙住眼睛。还有，珍娜，我不知道你还记不记得，可怜的布莱恩，他们让他待在背景里。他只是在吃他的鸡蛋。
And it didn't make it on camera. And I remember feeling so bad that Brian, in the course of this time, in the heat, had to eat hard-boiled eggs and hot dogs. I was like, this poor guy. And also, I think it's very funny that Michael hard-boiled the eggs. Yes. Because then if they fall up the spoon, it doesn't matter. There's no point. There's no point.
而且这没被拍进镜头里。我记得当时觉得很过意不去，布莱恩在这段时间里，在高温下，不得不吃水煮蛋和热狗。我当时想，这个可怜的家伙。而且，我觉得迈克尔把鸡蛋煮熟了非常搞笑。是的。因为这样如果他们从勺子上掉下来也没关系。没意义。没意义。
Now, I am wondering, and I don't know the answer, I am speculating, but I wonder if we had to hardboil the eggs because we couldn't risk having eggs break on the beach and sort of leaving behind that kind of debris. Because when we left there, we had to make it seem like we'd never been there at all. Not only that, but there's no way we could be dealing with wardrobe issues with egg yolk. Yes, exactly. But I like to think that it was just Michael's strange choice, but it was probably a very, very practical one. Oh, I'm sure it was very thought out. I wrote, what the heck? Who is setting up these tiki torches?
现在，我在想，我不知道答案，我只是在推测，但我怀疑我们是否必须把鸡蛋煮熟，因为我们不能冒险让鸡蛋在沙滩上破碎，留下那种残骸。因为当我们离开那里时，我们必须让它看起来好像我们从来没去过那里一样。不仅如此，我们也不可能处理蛋黄带来的服装问题。是的，没错。但我喜欢认为这只是迈克尔奇怪的选择，但这可能是一个非常、非常实际的选择。哦，我肯定这是经过深思熟虑的。我写道，搞什么鬼？是谁在布置这些火把？
Where did the blindfolds come in? Who carried the eggs? Who had the spoons? What is happening? Oh, Angela, I don't know if it's in the deleted scenes, but in the script, there was an extra scene where Dwight discovers these boxes of supplies. that Michael has packed in the back of the bus. And he's trying to get Michael to tell him what they are. What are the torches for?
眼罩是从哪来的？谁带的鸡蛋？谁拿的勺子？发生了什么？哦，安吉拉，我不知道这是否在删除片段里，但在剧本里，有一个额外的场景，德怀特发现了这些迈克尔装在巴士后面的补给箱。他试图让迈克尔告诉他这些是什么。火把是干什么用的？
What is this for, Michael? And Michael's like, stop badgering me. That is in the deleted scenes, but it's just a bag where he's trying to zip up. And Dwight's like, is that a sumo suit? Are we going to do Japanese business exercises? And, but none of the other supplies are seen. And I guess my whole point is fine, fine, Jenna.
这是干什么用的，迈克尔？迈克尔说，别烦我。那是在删除片段里，但这只是一个他试图拉上拉链的袋子。德怀特说，那是相扑服吗？我们要进行日本商务练习吗？但是其他补给品都没出现。我想我的重点是，好吧，好吧，珍娜。
He had the supplies on the back of the bus. Who's setting them up? Where's my B-roll footage of Dwight having to run around and stab Tiki torches in the ground? Well, I know I'm jumping ahead, but later we're going to see two guys setting a giant fire pit thing. With a red pickup truck. Who are these dudes? I guess. I don't know.
他把补给品放在巴士后面。是谁在布置它们？我那段德怀特不得不跑来跑去把火把插在地上的花絮镜头呢？嗯，我知道我跳得太快了，但稍后我们会看到两个家伙在设置一个巨大的火坑之类的东西。用一辆红色皮卡车。这些家伙是谁？我猜。我不知道。
Michael had some assistance. Okay. We just have to suspend belief a little bit, guys. I guess so. Well, during this egg race, at 9 minutes 54 seconds, you can fully see Mindy. starting to laugh. Oh, yeah. When Ed is yelling at her, when she's afraid she's going to run into the big rock,
迈克尔得到了一些帮助。好吧。我们只需要稍微暂停一下怀疑，伙计们。我想是吧。嗯，在这次鸡蛋赛跑期间，在9分54秒，你可以完全看到明迪开始笑。哦，是的。当艾德对她大喊大叫时，当她害怕自己会撞到大石头时，
she starts laughing. Yes. And I personally love how Ryan says to Dwight, if you keep shouting at me, I'm going to stop. I'm going to stop this race. And he doesn't stop shouting, so he just takes off his blindfold and throws his spoon on the ground. Now, Jenna, I think there's a portion of that scene that was on the fly. kind of scene, and that was improvised dialogue between BJ and Rain. That's what they talked about in the DVD commentary.
她开始笑了。是的。我个人很喜欢瑞安对德怀特说的话，如果你继续对我大喊大叫，我就要停下来了。我要停止这场比赛。他没有停止大喊，所以他只是摘下眼罩，把勺子扔在地上。现在，珍娜，我认为那个场景中有一部分是即兴的，那是BJ和雷恩之间的即兴对话。这就是他们在DVD评论中谈到的。
Do you remember that? Yes, yes, that's right. Well, now Pam has her talking head where we see that she's taking her diligent notes. And we had some fan questions from Lily S., Ashley Hildreth and Madison Barton. Jenna, did you really write the notes? And if so, what did you write? I'm with you. I want to know, too.
你还记得吗？是的，是的，没错。嗯，现在帕姆有了她的访谈，我们看到她在认真做笔记。我们收到了一些来自莉莉·S、阿什利·希尔德雷斯和麦迪逊·巴顿的粉丝提问。珍娜，你真的写了笔记吗？如果是的话，你写了什么？我和你一样。我也想知道。
I'm like, I know my BFF and I'm guessing you actually were writing things down. What were you doing? I was taking diligent notes. I knew it. I knew it. In character. Yeah. So there's a moment where I hold up my notebook and I tried to freeze on it to see if I could copy down what is said.
我心想，我了解我最好的朋友，我猜你真的在写东西。你在做什么？我在认真做笔记。我就知道。我就知道。在角色里。是的。所以有一个时刻我举起我的笔记本，我试着定格在上面，看看能不能抄下上面写的东西。
And it was too fuzzy, but you can see that I am writing, you know, Dwight did this, Dwight did that, Jim did this. I thought that the best way to get through those scenes was to actually write down what was happening around me, as if I was in character. I figured you were. So you can see Michael is losing people. Like Stanley is so happy Phyllis dropped the egg. He's going to go sit down. He's going to do his crossword on his lawn chair. Creed wanders off.
它太模糊了，但你可以看到我在写，你知道，德怀特做了这个，德怀特做了那个，吉姆做了这个。我认为度过那些场景的最好方法就是真的写下我周围发生的事情，就好像我身处角色中一样。我猜你就是这样。所以你可以看到迈克尔正在失去人心。比如斯坦利很高兴菲利斯掉了鸡蛋。他要去坐下。他要在他的草坪椅上做填字游戏。克里德走开了。
And in the background, we see him catch a fish with his bare hands. Yeah. Well, there's a really fun little tidbit about that on the DVD commentary. Harold said, you guys, this is how we did it. There was a rubber fish that they sort of submerged, like, in a bucket. What you can't see is this rubber fish in water in a bucket. And they really were able to cheat it because Creed's a little bit over the hill, you know? Yeah.
在背景中，我们看到他徒手抓到了一条鱼。是的。嗯，DVD评论里有一个关于这个的非常有趣的片段。哈罗德说，伙计们，我们是这样做的。有一条橡胶鱼，他们把它浸没在桶里。你看不见的是这个桶里的水里的橡胶鱼。他们真的能够作弊，因为克里德有点老糊涂了，你知道吗？是的。
And he reaches down real fast and he pulls it out. But I thought Creed did a great job of selling that. That was some good hand acting. It was. And Harold said true to Hollywood form, this gag, that rubber fish, cost $500. Well, here's an interesting tidbit. Fishing is not allowed on Lakes Granton. Oh, that's true.
他很快地伸手下去，把它拉了出来。但我认为克里德在推销这一点上做得很好。那是一些很好的手部表演。确实。哈罗德说，按照好莱坞的惯例，这个噱头，那条橡胶鱼，花了500美元。嗯，这里有一个有趣的片段。格兰顿湖禁止钓鱼。哦，那是真的。
But maybe if you're a creed and you grab it with your bare hands. Well, you know what that scene reminded me of, Angela. What? The edge. Oh, good Lord. The edge. Having to just get the fish. You got to.
但也许如果你是克里德，你徒手抓它。嗯，你知道那个场景让我想起了什么吗，安吉拉。什么？《荒野求生》。哦，天哪。《荒野求生》。不得不去抓那条鱼。你必须得抓。
I mean, I don't know if anyone actually catches a fish with the fish. their hand in the edge. But I mean, that's survival. Maybe the bear did. The bear did. Oh, I won't bring up the bear. I know it's, I know it's a trigger for you. I really think you need to watch the series alone about these survivalists in the woods, because that's what it made me think of now. Maybe I should. Okay. I'm currently really obsessed with The Chef Show. The Chef Show. Okay, so John Favro, who incidentally, directed an episode of The Office in season nine. We'll get to it.
我是说，我不知道是否有人真的在《荒野求生》里徒手抓鱼。但我的意思是，那是生存。也许那只熊抓到了。那只熊抓到了。哦，我不会提起那只熊。我知道，我知道这对你来说是个触发点。我真的认为你需要独自观看这个关于森林里生存者的系列节目，因为这就是它让我想到的。也许我应该。我目前真的很迷《主厨秀》。《主厨秀》。好吧，乔恩·费儒，顺便说一句，他在第九季执导了一集《办公室》。我们会讲到的。
Yeah. He has this movie called Chef, and it's so good. Came out several years ago. It's one of my favorite movies. Well, he is obsessed with bread baking and cooking. And so he has started this series called The Chef Show, where he goes and he interviews different chefs while they make their signature dishes. I can't get enough of it.
是的。他有一部电影叫《落魄大厨》，太棒了。几年前上映的。这是我最喜欢的电影之一。嗯，他痴迷于面包烘焙和烹饪。所以他开始了名为《主厨秀》的系列节目，他去采访不同的厨师，同时制作他们的招牌菜。我怎么看都看不够。
You must love it. Now, this is a total tangent, but Isabel and I, I love the greatest British bake-off. We love it so much. And it's, it checks off all my boxes. It's like in the beautiful English countryside. Yeah. And I just love, I love everything. Like, especially when things don't go well, they'll say like, it's a bit of a disaster, wasn't it? Yes. Quite Father Paul. Yeah. I know. So matter of fact. I love that show as well. That show is the show that got me to start making bread. Oh, I didn't know that. Yeah. Yeah. That's my bread. origin story. My gosh, we are very off topic. We are very off topic and we have a lot to cover. We've got to get to this hot dog eating contest. Let's do it. We have a scene. Michael comes up to Pam and hands her 800 hot dogs that she needs to have ready in 10 minutes. What was Michael's budget for this day? I don't know. Where did he get the money for this? Just the 800 hot dogs alone. I know. How much does that cost? Can someone do some math on that? 800 please.
你一定很喜欢它。现在，这是一个完全的题外话，但伊莎贝尔和我，我喜欢《英国烘焙大赛》。我们太喜欢它了。它满足了我所有的要求。它就像在美丽的英国乡村。是的。我只是喜欢，我喜欢一切。尤其是当事情进展不顺利时，他们会说，这有点像一场灾难，不是吗？是的。保罗神父。是的。我知道。太客观了。我也喜欢那个节目。那个节目是让我开始做面包的节目。哦，我不知道。是的。是的。那是我的面包起源故事。天哪，我们跑题太远了。我们跑题太远了，还有很多要讲。我们得讲到这个热狗大胃王比赛。开始吧。我们有一个场景。迈克尔走到帕姆面前，递给她800个热狗，让她在10分钟内准备好。迈克尔这一天的预算是多少？我不知道。他从哪弄来的钱？光是800个热狗。我知道。那要花多少钱？有人能算算吗？800个，拜托。
I need to know how much money Michael spent on hot dogs. Well, also during that scene, and this is slightly off topic, but also not. We got some mail about it. At 11 minutes, 27 seconds, you can see my bra strap. Oh. And a lot of people wanted to know, why am I wearing a bra and a bathing suit? So here are my layers for the day. guys, I had on a bra because I like wearing them.
我需要知道迈克尔在热狗上花了多少钱。嗯，在那个场景中，这稍微有点跑题，但也不完全是。我们收到了一些关于它的邮件。在11分27秒，你可以看到我的内衣肩带。哦。很多人想知道，为什么我穿着内衣和泳衣？所以这是我当天的分层穿搭。伙计们，我穿了内衣，因为我喜欢穿它们。
That's why I have a bra on because I didn't want to wear just a flimsy swimming suit top. I like some support. On top of the bra, I'm wearing my wardrobe swimming suit top, which I loved because Carrie Bennett, she came up with this idea that if it was like a halter suit, we would get an indication of a bathing suit, even though you never see me in the bathing suit. I thought it was a great idea. Right. Then I have on a tank top, and the reason I'm wearing the tank top is to cover up the bra strap.
这就是为什么我穿了内衣，因为我不想只穿一件单薄的泳衣上衣。我喜欢一些支撑。在内衣外面，我穿着我的戏服泳衣上衣，我很喜欢它，因为凯莉·贝内特想出了这个主意，如果它像挂脖泳衣，我们就会有一种泳衣的暗示，即使你从来没见过我穿泳衣。我觉得这是个好主意。对。然后我穿了一件背心，我穿背心的原因是遮住内衣肩带。
We had a little bit of a fail here at 11 minutes, 27 seconds. And then I'm wearing a hoodie. Those were my layers. So I guess somehow Pam cooked these hot dogs. I mean, she has a glance to camera where she's like, I don't know, maybe I didn't cook them. There is a deleted scene between Pam and Michael where she is grilling the hot dogs. And he comes over and he's like, speed it up, Pam, why aren't these done yet? and you're like, because there's 800 of them.
我们在11分27秒这里有点失误。然后我穿着一件连帽衫。这就是我的分层穿搭。所以我猜帕姆不知怎么地煮了这些热狗。我是说，她有一个看向镜头的眼神，好像在说，我不知道，也许我没煮它们。帕姆和迈克尔之间有一个删除片段，她在烤热狗。他走过来，说，快点，帕姆，为什么这些还没好？你说，因为有800个。
Amazing. Amazing. So now it's time for the big hot dog eating contest. Where, by the way, Michael takes credit for cooking up the hot dogs. I know. I know. And there is a wonderful deleted scene, Jenna. It wasn't scripted.
太棒了。太棒了。现在是热狗大胃王比赛的时间了。顺便说一句，迈克尔把煮热狗的功劳揽在自己身上。我知道。我知道。有一个精彩的删除片段，珍娜。那不是剧本里的。
It was a collective improv moment. When Michael says, dip it in the water so it will slide down your gullet more easily, our whole table said, that's what she said. I remember that. And it didn't make it in, but it's so good. That's because that line from Steve was an improvisation. He, in the script, he yells at Phyllis, dip it in the water, dip it in the water. But that's all that was scripted.
这是一个集体的即兴时刻。当迈克尔说，把它蘸在水里，这样它就能更容易地滑进你的食道时，我们整桌人都说，那是她说的。我记得那个。它没被放进去，但太棒了。那是因为史蒂夫的那句台词是即兴发挥的。在剧本里，他对着菲利斯大喊，把它蘸在水里，把它蘸在水里。但剧本里只有这些。
So Steve in the moment added the so it'll slide down your gullet faster. And then we all, I mean, how can you not? How can you not? How can you not? That was a layup. No, that was a softball. Isn't a layup and a softball sort of the same idea? I don't know.
所以史蒂夫当时加了“这样它就能更快地滑进你的食道”。然后我们所有人，我是说，你怎么能不呢？你怎么能不呢？你怎么能不呢？那是一个上篮。不，那是一个垒球。上篮和垒球不是同一个概念吗？我不知道。
A layup? After I've thought about it, I'm going to give this to softball because a softball involves more than one person, right? Yeah. So a softball, one person sends a softball to another who then hits it out of the park. Whereas with a layup, you do it on your own. You do it on your own. And, I mean, a layup through a crowd is not easy. to do if there's a bunch of guys in the paint let me throw some basketball at you but maybe if you got
上篮？我想了一下，我要把它归为垒球，因为垒球涉及不止一个人，对吧？是的。所以垒球，一个人把球传给另一个人，然后那个人把它打出场外。而上篮，你是自己完成的。你是自己完成的。而且，我是说，在人群中上篮并不容易，如果禁区里有一堆人的话，让我给你讲讲篮球，但也许如果你有
talking about what do you think a layup is if you hold on a second hold on a second what's the last time you did a layup I did one this week what is it to you a layup is when you dribble up to the basket and you put it in on your own but I'm telling you if you're doing a layup you know and you're being if you're doing a layup and you're being guarded but this is you're doing a layup and you're being guarded then there's the breakaway layup, right? If you steal the ball and you got the whole back of the court to yourself and you're like, yeah, and you do your layup. And then sometimes you want to dunk on your layup, hard for me because I'm 5'1. What's happening right now? I don't know. Where are we? What is, what? Wait. Do you watch basketball? Are you like a basketball fan? Where's all this lingo coming from? I play basketball. I played JV. And then when everyone got really tall, I had to stop playing because I was too short. And we had a really good point. guard. So then I became a basketball cheerleader and I was also the manager on the basketball team and I was also a mascot one basketball season and I love basketball and we have a hoop in our driveway and we play all the time and I have a fantastic outside shot and I often win at horse.
谈论你认为上篮是什么，等一下，等一下，你上次上篮是什么时候？我这周做了一个，对你来说上篮是什么？上篮就是你运球到篮下，然后自己把它放进去，但我告诉你，如果你在做上篮，你知道，如果你在做上篮并且被防守，那么有快攻上篮，对吧？如果你抢断了球，整个后场都是你的，你就像，耶，然后你做你的上篮。有时你想在你的上篮上扣篮，对我来说很难，因为我只有5英尺1英寸。现在发生了什么？我不知道。我们在哪？什么，什么？等等。你看篮球吗？你是篮球迷吗？这些术语是从哪来的？我打篮球。我打过校队。然后当每个人都变得很高时，我不得不停止打球，因为我太矮了。我们有一个很好的控球后卫。所以我后来成了篮球啦啦队长，我也是篮球队的经理，我还在一个篮球赛季当过吉祥物，我喜欢篮球，我们的车道上有个篮筐，我们经常玩，我的外线投篮很棒，我经常在“马”游戏里赢。
Angela, I'm clapping because people couldn't see me bowing down to you. But I mean, I'm speechless I did not know this about you. And also, I mean, I defer to you here. If this were a debate and someone had to win, you won. I mean, that was just. I want you to know, it's not out yet, but I have this Advil commercial where I have to shoot baskets. And I made like 13 baskets in a row. And one of them they used in the actual shot.
安吉拉，我在鼓掌，因为人们看不到我在向你鞠躬。但我是说，我无语了，我不知道你还有这一面。而且，我是说，我在这里听你的。如果这是一场辩论，有人必须赢，你赢了。我是说，那真是。我想让你知道，虽然还没出来，但我有个Advil广告，我必须投篮。我连续投进了13个球。其中一个被用在了实际拍摄中。
And I was so happy that they showed the whole shot because I was like, I made that sucker. you were Brian Baumgartner while shooting the basketball episode. You have like a secret basketball skill that no one knew about. Don't you remember the basketball hoop by our trailers and we would play horse? I was always out there with the guys playing horse. I do remember that and I have a picture of it. Yeah. Well, listen, I feel like we've gone off topic.
我很高兴他们展示了整个投篮过程，因为我当时想，我投进了那个家伙。你在拍摄篮球那一集时就像布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳。你有一种没人知道的秘密篮球技巧。你不记得我们拖车旁边的篮球架了吗？我们会玩“马”游戏？我总是和男人们在那里玩“马”游戏。我记得，我还有一张照片。是的。好吧，听着，我觉得我们跑题了。
Do you think? Wait, we're back to the hot dogs, guys. Back to the hot dogs. Andy wins the competition, but this was an arduous scene for everyone to shoot. I was really lucky, Jenna, because I said my character's a vegetarian. She's not going to be eating these. I made a really big plea about that. But poor Brian and Ed, Leslie, all those guys were shoving hot dogs in their face.
你觉得吗？等等，我们回到热狗了，伙计们。回到热狗。安迪赢了比赛，但这对每个人来说都是一场艰苦的拍摄。我真的很幸运，珍娜，因为我说我的角色是素食主义者。她不会吃这些的。我为此做了很大的恳求。但可怜的布莱恩和艾德、莱斯利，所有那些家伙都在往脸上塞热狗。
And Jenna, do you remember they were starting to gag? Do you remember that? Yeah, you know, we got a fan question from Caitlin. Mulvahill who said, how many times did you have to film the hot dog contest scene and did you have to eat all the hot dogs every time? I just remember it took a long time. It was a lot of angles, a lot of coverage. A lot of reaction shots. We were there for like half a day. Yeah. And Jen, we asked Jen, what was the hardest stunt during beach games? And this is what she had to say.
珍娜，你记得他们开始干呕了吗？你记得吗？是的，你知道，我们收到了凯特琳·穆尔瓦希尔的粉丝提问，她说，你们拍了多少次热狗比赛场景，你们每次都必须吃掉所有的热狗吗？我只记得花了好长时间。有很多角度，很多覆盖镜头。很多反应镜头。我们在那里待了半天。是的。珍娜，我们问了珍，海滩游戏中最难的特技是什么？她是这么说的。
I think the answer for what was the hardest stunt of this episode depends on who you ask. I think for the actors, it was possibly the hot dog eating contest. I'm curious what you guys think. I remember spit buckets. I could be wrong about that, but I'm fairly certain there were a bunch of spit buckets. But there was some actual eating of hot dogs. And I think Ed Helms ate an enormous amount of hot dogs, if I remember correctly. I think he was going really hard.
我认为这一集最难的特技是什么取决于你问谁。我认为对于演员来说，可能是热狗大胃王比赛。我很好奇你们怎么想。我记得有吐痰桶。我可能记错了，但我相当肯定有一堆吐痰桶。但确实有实际吃热狗的过程。而且我认为艾德·赫尔姆斯吃了很多热狗，如果我没记错的话。我想他真的很努力。
for winning the contest. So I think that that was probably a lot of people's answers. For me, it was getting the shot during the Michael talking head of Andy floating away at sea. Yes, we will get to that. She sent in some more amazing stuff about that stunt. But I do remember the spit buckets, Zange. I do too. And one of the things, you guys, on some shows, the way they,
为了赢得比赛。所以我认为这可能是很多人的答案。对我来说，是在迈克尔访谈中拍摄安迪在海上漂走的镜头。是的，我们会讲到的。她发了一些关于那个特技的更精彩的内容。但我确实记得吐痰桶，赞吉。我也记得。而且有一件事，伙计们，在一些节目中，他们拍摄的方式，
shoot, you know when you're on camera. And when you're off camera, you don't have to sort of participate. You can kind of not eat, right? But the way we shot this, there was a huge group shot, right? There's a camera that's capturing everything. So these guys had to eat on every take because they never knew when the camera was specifically on them or not. And I remember when they would yell cut, immediately, like the prop guys would run over with buckets and these guys would all start spitting in the buckets, because they couldn't have the buckets on the ground. There was nowhere to hide them, right? And so the prop guys would run over with the buckets, and Ed said this thing in the DVD
你知道什么时候在镜头前。当你不在镜头前时，你不必参与。你可以不吃，对吧？但我们拍摄的方式，有一个巨大的集体镜头，对吧？有一台摄像机在捕捉一切。所以这些家伙在每次拍摄时都必须吃，因为他们不知道摄像机什么时候专门对着他们。我记得当他们喊停时，道具组的人会立刻跑过来拿着桶，这些家伙就会开始往桶里吐，因为他们不能把桶放在地上。没地方藏，对吧？所以道具组的人会跑过来拿着桶，艾德在DVD里说了这件事
commentary. He said, first of all, spitting out food that I've been chewing and holding in my mouth, the action of spitting out this chewed food would activate my gag reflex. So I'd start gagging. And he said, but then on top of that, this bucket that they would bring around, several other people had spit their food out into? He said just all of it. All of it, he said, like, they were all getting so grossed out. Well, this scene really reminded me of that birthday cake scene from Meredith's birthday, where we all ate cake. Made chocolate chip ice cream cake. I can't
评论。他说，首先，吐出我咀嚼并含在嘴里的食物，吐出这些咀嚼过的食物的动作会激活我的呕吐反射。所以我开始干呕。他说，但除此之外，他们拿来的这个桶，其他几个人也把食物吐进去了？他说简直是，全部。全部，他说，就像，他们都被恶心到了。嗯，这个场景真的让我想起了梅雷迪斯生日那天那个生日蛋糕的场景，我们都吃了蛋糕。做了巧克力豆冰淇淋蛋糕。我到现在都不能
eat it to this day. I can't eat it. Same. We ate so much of it because we never knew when we were on camera and then like that, I feel like there's barely any footage in this episode of these guys eating the hot dogs. It does not accurately reflect how much hot dog eating happened. Not at all. These poor guys. And Jim isn't eating the hot dogs. There's a deleted scene where he brought a tuna salad and he is not even participating. So John did not have to do this. And neither did I. And neither did Steve. Oh, God. Well, Jenna, so Andy wins with 13 hot dogs, right?
吃它。我吃不下。我也是。我们吃了太多，因为我们不知道什么时候在镜头前，然后就像那样，我觉得这一集里几乎没有这些家伙吃热狗的镜头。它并没有准确反映出吃了多少热狗。一点也不。这些可怜的家伙。吉姆没吃热狗。有一个删除片段，他带了金枪鱼沙拉，他甚至没参与。所以约翰不必这样做。我也没做。史蒂夫也没做。哦，天哪。好吧，珍娜，所以安迪以13个热狗赢了，对吧？
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. I just looked up this year the hot dog eating contest, the Nathan's hot dog eating contest for 2020. Oh, lady. Did you two? Did you too? Because I've been to the hot dog eating contest. What?
嗯嗯。嗯嗯。我刚查了今年的热狗大胃王比赛，2020年内森热狗大胃王比赛。哦，女士。你也查了？你也查了？因为我去过热狗大胃王比赛。什么？
Yeah. When? In 2011. What? How? I went to Coney Island. Lee and I were in New York. We were looking for something to do over July 4th weekend.
是的。什么时候？2011年。什么？怎么会？我去了康尼岛。李和我在纽约。我们在寻找7月4日周末可以做的事情。
And you went to it? We saw that the Coney Island hot dog eating, we got on the subway and we rode it out there. I was very pregnant. I was like seven months pregnant. Oh my gosh. I did not know any of this. See, you think you know your best friend. And then all of a sudden she's going to hot dog eating contest and she knows how to play basketball.
你去了？我们看到康尼岛热狗大胃王比赛，我们上了地铁，骑车去了那里。我当时怀孕了。我当时怀孕七个月。天哪。我一点都不知道。看，你以为你了解你最好的朋友。然后突然她去参加热狗大胃王比赛，她还知道怎么打篮球。
Yeah, exactly. And here's my memory. It was super exciting. We only saw the men's contest. I saw Joey Chestnut win the hot dog eating contest. He won again this year. Yeah, and he broke his world record this year. His nickname is Jaws, Joey Jaws Chestnut.
是的，没错。这是我的记忆。太令人兴奋了。我们只看了男子比赛。我看到乔伊·切斯纳特赢得了热狗大胃王比赛。他今年又赢了。是的，他今年打破了他的世界纪录。他的绰号是“大白鲨”，乔伊·大白鲨·切斯纳特。
Yeah, this year, because we both looked it up, Joey Chestnut. ate 75 hot dogs and buns in 10 minutes. And Jenna, in the female category, Miki Sudo, ate 48 and a half hot dogs in 10 minutes and now has the new world record. Yeah, Joey Chestnut has won every year since 2007, with the exception of one year in 2015, Matt Stoney won. But Joey has won every year since. And Miki has won every year since 2014. I will say one thing when I went to the hot dog eating contest
是的，今年，因为我们都查过了，乔伊·切斯纳特在10分钟内吃了75个热狗和面包。珍娜，在女性类别中，美纪须藤在10分钟内吃了48个半热狗，现在有了新的世界纪录。是的，乔伊·切斯纳特自2007年以来每年都赢，除了2015年，马特·斯托尼赢了一次。但乔伊自那以后每年都赢。美纪自2014年以来每年都赢。我得说一件事，当我去热狗大胃王比赛时
I mentioned I was very pregnant I had to pee and there were no restrooms and all of the businesses because there's such a giant influx of people that come down they all have signs that say no public restroom no public restroom no public restroom you can't just go in and use their bathroom
我提到我怀孕了，我得去洗手间，但没有洗手间，所有的商家因为有大量的人涌入，他们都挂着牌子说没有公共洗手间，没有公共洗手间，没有公共洗手间，你不能进去用他们的洗手间
but I found an employee at the Dunkin' Donuts who sneaked me in and let me use the bathroom there and I still to this day I want to say thank you so much for helping me relieve my pregnant bladder that day. Thank you, nice person at Dunkin' Donuts on Coney Island in 2011. You know, if you were Meredith, like the deleted scene, you would have just gone and squat in the bushes right by the bus. Oh, no.
但我找到了一个唐恩都乐的员工，他把我偷偷带进去，让我用了那里的洗手间，直到今天，我想说非常感谢你那天帮我缓解了怀孕的膀胱。谢谢你，2011年康尼岛唐恩都乐的好心人。你知道，如果你是梅雷迪斯，就像那个删除片段一样，你就会直接去巴士旁边的灌木丛里蹲着了。哦，不。
Poor Kate. Kate in this episode. Oh, my God. Well, maybe, Angela, on that note, we should take a break here and both use the restroom. Mm-hmm. And then we'll come back with some sabotage. Sandwich. Now I said sandwich earlier. This time I'm saying sabotage. Okay, we are back.
可怜的凯特。这一集的凯特。哦，天哪。好吧，也许，安吉拉，说到这里，我们应该在这里休息一下，都去用一下洗手间。嗯嗯。然后我们会带着一些破坏回来。三明治。我刚才说了三明治。这次我说的是破坏。好吧，我们回来了。
And oh, Angela, I love this scene so much. I rewound it and watched it twice. I do love this scene. It's one of my favorites. So this is the scene where Dwight and Angela have tiptoed away from the group. And they're having a private conversation about sabotage. Dwight would like Angela to sabotage her team. Yes, the ancient art, like Dutch sabotage.
哦，安吉拉，我太喜欢这个场景了。我倒回去看了两遍。我确实喜欢这个场景。这是我最喜欢的场景之一。这是德怀特和安吉拉从人群中溜走的场景。他们正在进行关于破坏的私人谈话。德怀特希望安吉拉破坏她的团队。是的，古老的艺术，像荷兰式破坏。
I was like, what? This scene was so fun to film. First of all, I remember Jen and Harold and Rain and I trying to figure out where Dwight and I would be. where it would really look like we were away from everyone and also that we would think that we got away with it, right? Yes. And that the spy shot would have to be far enough away. So we did sort of climb.
我当时想，什么？这个场景拍起来太有趣了。首先，我记得珍、哈罗德、雷恩和我试图弄清楚德怀特和我会在哪里。在哪里看起来真的像我们远离了所有人，而且我们也会认为我们逃脱了惩罚，对吧？是的。而且间谍镜头必须足够远。所以我们确实爬了。
There were these little sand dunes, Jenna. Do you remember? They were sort of small and they had like big sort of like tall kind of grass growing out of them. Yeah, like reedy grass coming out of them. Itchy, itchy reedy grass. Like it kind of like cut you a little if it touched your skin. but we sort of tucked back in there for this scene and there are some great bloopers and it's mostly just me laughing because I could not get through it when he said sabotage and I said
有一些小沙丘，珍娜。你记得吗？它们有点小，上面长着像大块的、高高的草。是的，像芦苇一样的草从里面长出来。痒痒的，痒痒的芦苇草。就像如果它碰到你的皮肤，它会割伤你一点。但我们为了这个场景躲在里面，有一些很棒的NG镜头，大部分只是我在笑，因为当他说破坏，我说
sandwich every single time the absurdity of these two not to mention I could hear Jen Slotta laughing from her little group of bushes where her and Harold were hiding and I would be like Jen, stop laughing. I just got it together. And now Jen is laughing. And you couldn't see her. It was just like this little clump of bushes that was like. Oh, my gosh.
三明治时，我每次都无法坚持下去，这两个人的荒谬，更不用说我能听到珍·斯洛塔从她和哈罗德躲藏的小灌木丛里发出的笑声，我会说珍，别笑了。我刚调整好状态。现在珍又在笑了。你看不见她。它就像那一小丛灌木。哦，天哪。
I love it so much. I love the end when Dwight says, if Michael organizes a group hug, stand next to me. Jen told me she loved writing for Dwight and Angela, that she loved their sort of suppressed love for one another. Yeah. Oh, it's such a good scene. Such a good scene. One thing about the scene that made it tricky that you might not think of is that this is one of the few times where Dwight and I have to be standing facing one another and you really see our height difference. I knew it was a wide shot because it was a spy shot, but now it makes me think it was also that wide to fit you both in frame.
我太喜欢了。我喜欢结尾，德怀特说，如果迈克尔组织集体拥抱，站在我旁边。珍告诉我她喜欢为德怀特和安吉拉写剧本，她喜欢他们那种对彼此压抑的爱。是的。哦，这是一个很好的场景。很好的场景。关于这个场景的一个棘手之处，你可能想不到，这是德怀特和我不得不面对面站着的少数几次之一，你真的能看到我们的身高差。我知道这是一个广角镜头，因为它是一个间谍镜头，但现在它让我想起它也那么宽是为了把你们两个都放进画面里。
Yes. And the other thing, the other thing to point out, which I thought was really great, is you can really see that Dwight is wearing. a Cooper Seafood T-shirt. Hey. A little local Scranton reference there. I know. Well, next up is the sumo competition. Oh, my goodness, Jenna.
是的。还有另一件事，另一件要指出的事，我觉得非常好，就是你可以真的看到德怀特穿着一件库珀海鲜T恤。嘿。一个当地斯克兰顿的参考。我知道。好吧，接下来是相扑比赛。哦，天哪，安吉拉。
Where to begin? Where to begin? Where to begin? I'll tell you, I did one of those like a goofaw. Is that the word where you laugh out loud? Like it just like it takes over your body and you can't even suppress it. when I saw John in his little toothpick legs walk out in that sumo suit, look at his legs. If you have it, look at his tiny little legs sticking out of that sumo suit and his little head popping up.
从哪开始？从哪开始？从哪开始？我告诉你，我做了一个那种大笑。那是大声笑出来的词吗？就像它占据了你的身体，你甚至无法抑制它。当我看到约翰穿着那件相扑服，迈着牙签腿走出来时，看他的腿。如果你有的话，看看他那双从相扑服里伸出来的小细腿，还有他那颗探出来的小脑袋。
It made me laugh so hard. Now, I know that those guys were just so hot in those suits. Oh, yeah. They were dying. And we had these little fans that they would. try to like cool them off with but i'm sure that they were just so sweaty but they also had the best time in those they were like they all turned into children and they were loving it i have to say they couldn't wait to run at each other and like throw themselves at each other and all of it
这让我笑得太厉害了。现在，我知道那些家伙在那些衣服里太热了。哦，是的。他们快死了。我们有这些小风扇，他们会试着给他们降温，但我肯定他们汗流浃背，但他们在那些衣服里也玩得最开心，他们就像，他们都变成了孩子，他们很喜欢。我必须说，他们迫不及待地想冲向对方，像那样把自己扔向对方，所有这些
they were having so much fun but i do remember between takes they could not sit down yes they could not sit down and people would run over with like little umbrellas and these fans to try to cool them off. And Jenna, I was hanging out with Rain and I have this great photo that one of the things I loved is that I could lean on Rain's belly like I had something to prop myself up on. So I have this photo and it's him and I casually talking, but I'm resting myself on his sumo belly. That's incredible. Well, we had a fan question from Freya McKenzie. And Jesse Magison, is it true that Rayne Wilson actually put Leslie David Baker in the hospital while shooting beach games? Yes.
他们玩得太开心了，但我确实记得在拍摄间隙，他们不能坐下，是的，他们不能坐下，人们会跑过来拿着小雨伞和这些风扇试图给他们降温。安吉拉，我和雷恩待在一起，我有一张很棒的照片，我喜欢的一件事是我可以靠在雷恩的肚子上，就像我有东西支撑自己一样。所以我拍了这张照片，是他和我随意交谈，但我靠在他的相扑肚皮上。这太不可思议了。好吧，我们收到了来自弗雷亚·麦肯齐和杰西·马吉森的粉丝提问，雷恩·威尔逊在拍摄海滩游戏时真的把莱斯利·大卫·贝克送进医院了吗？是的。
What happened was that during all this sumo wrestling, Leslie got sand in his eyes and they tried to flush it out, but they couldn't. And I remember he had to leave set. And I don't know if he went to the hospital or to an eye doctor, but he had a scratched cornea. Yeah, I thought they took him to a local, like the clinic, the nearest hospital. Every single day when you're filming, whether it's on set or location, they put in the call sheet, the location where you're filming, and the nearest hospital's location. Yeah, they researched that ahead of time for this reason. So I think they took him to the nearest, whatever that was, clinic, right? Yeah.
发生的事情是，在所有这些相扑摔跤过程中，莱斯利眼睛里进了沙子，他们试图冲洗出来，但没成功。我记得他不得不离开片场。我不知道他是去了医院还是眼科医生那里，但他角膜擦伤了。是的，我以为他们带他去了当地的，比如诊所，最近的医院。每天拍摄时，无论是在片场还是外景地，他们都会在通告单上写上拍摄地点和最近的医院位置。是的，他们为了这个原因提前研究过。所以我认为他们带他去了最近的，无论那是什么，诊所，对吧？是的。
And he was in quite a bit of pain, and he was like, no, it's still in there. There's something wrong. You know that moment in your body where you're like, it's not right. Something's not right. And it had, in fact, scratched his cornea. And they treated him. And then he came back and finished filming because he's such a trooper. Well, I've had this happen to me, Angela.
他非常痛苦，他说，不，它还在里面。有什么不对劲。你知道你身体里那个时刻，你觉得，它不对劲。有什么不对劲。事实上，他的角膜擦伤了。他们治疗了他。然后他回来完成了拍摄，因为他是个硬汉。好吧，我发生过这种情况，安吉拉。
I got a piece of sand in my eye by using a face scrub with sand in it. Jenna. And I got a piece in my eye. And I was like, it feels like something's in your eye when you scratch your cornea. But I couldn't find it. So I went to an eye doctor and I had scratched my cornea. So I feel for Leslie, it is a very, it is a not fun feeling. I have never scratched my cornea.
我用含有沙子的面部磨砂膏时，沙子进了我的眼睛。珍娜。我眼睛里进了一块。我当时想，当你角膜擦伤时，感觉就像眼睛里有东西。但我找不到它。所以我去了眼科医生那里，我的角膜擦伤了。所以我同情莱斯利，那是一种非常不舒服的感觉。我从来没有擦伤过角膜。
But one time I was eating jalapeno potato chips because I love them so much. And I bit into it kind of aggressively. and the jalapeno dust off the chip went into my eyes, and it was very painful. Why are you laughing? This really happened. I bit into the chip, and then I was like, I got! Why am I laughing? How could you listen to that story and not laughing?
但有一次我在吃墨西哥辣椒薯片，因为我太喜欢它们了。我有点用力地咬了一口。薯片上的辣椒粉进了我的眼睛，非常痛苦。你为什么笑？这真的发生了。我咬了一口薯片，然后我就想，我中了！我为什么在笑？你怎么能听那个故事而不笑呢？
I don't know. I don't know. Okay, we should probably get back on topic. Yeah. Well, here's the thing. I remember Leslie. leaving set, but I don't remember when exactly it happened or how it happened. I just know he got sand in his eye. All right. This is what I think happened. I watched the deleted scenes
我不知道。我不知道。好吧，我们可能应该回到正题。是的。好吧，事情是这样的。我记得莱斯利离开片场，但我记不清具体是什么时候发生的，或者它是怎么发生的。我只知道他眼睛里进了沙子。好吧。这就是我认为发生的事情。我看了删除片段
and there's a moment. It's not in the episode where Dwight is wrestling with Stanley and knocks him to the ground and it's like, take that old man. And he kind of kicks at the sand, right? Oh, yes. I'm remembering this. And I think then Rain felt really bad because he realized in that moment he that's when he that's when we thought it happened yes that's right yeah that's right well this was not the only injury from this episode ed hurt his finger during the sumo wrestling do you remember that i think he like lost a fingernail or something he was like sorry it makes me laugh so hard i shouldn't laugh but it's when that moment if you guys watch it when andy and Dwight really start going at each other.
有一个时刻。它不在这一集里，德怀特和斯坦利摔跤，把他撞倒在地，说，尝尝这个，老头。他踢了踢沙子，对吧？哦，是的。我记得这个。我想当时雷恩觉得很内疚，因为他意识到在那一刻，那就是我们认为它发生的时候，是的，没错，是的，没错，好吧，这不是这一集里唯一的伤害，艾德在相扑摔跤时伤了手指。你记得吗？我想他好像丢了一个指甲什么的，他当时说，抱歉，这让我笑得太厉害了，我不该笑，但当那一刻，如果你们看的话，当安迪和德怀特真的开始对付对方时。
Like, Dwight walks over and he's eating a sandwich. Even though he's eating all these hot dogs, he walks over, and then they just start going on each other. And Ed is like kind of flailing his arms at him. Somehow in this tussle, Ed broke his fingernail. But he said he broke it really bad. Like it ripped. I think it like ripped below the...
就像，德怀特走过来，他在吃三明治。即使他在吃所有这些热狗，他走过来，然后他们就开始对付对方。艾德有点像在对他挥舞手臂。不知怎么地，在这场扭打中，艾德弄断了他的指甲。但他说是真的断得很厉害。就像撕裂了。我想它好像撕裂到了...
That's what I remember like, it was gruesome looking. But Ed was like yelling in his sumo suit. He was yelling, stop, stop. And all he could get out was, I broke my. nail. And people were like, okay, did you break your fingernail? And he's like, no, guys, I broke my nail. Oh, no. Oh, no. But he didn't leave set. No, he didn't leave set. They came over and they, but there was that moment when someone was like, what happened? Like, Ed broke his nail. And he's like, no, it's more than just a broken nail. And then they wrapped it up. Well, now, Angela, we're going to get into a big moment.
这就是我记得的，看起来很可怕。但艾德在相扑服里大喊，停下，停下。他只能喊出，我弄断了我的。指甲。人们说，好吧，你弄断了你的指甲？他说，不，伙计们，我弄断了我的指甲。哦，不。哦，不。但他没离开片场。不，他没离开片场。他们走过来，他们，但有那一刻，有人问，发生了什么？就像，艾德弄断了指甲。他说，不，这不仅仅是一个断指甲。然后他们包扎好了。好吧，现在，安吉拉，我们要进入一个大时刻。
This was huge for our show. This is a huge stunt. You have to remember, our show never left a little tiny office. So we've got a breakdown. We've got two big things coming up. We've got this Andy floating away and then the coals. So Jenna, let's start with Andy. Okay.
这对我们的节目来说是巨大的。这是一个巨大的特技。你必须记住，我们的节目从来没有离开过一个小小的办公室。所以我们有一个分解。我们有两件大事要来。我们有安迪漂走，然后是煤炭。所以珍娜，让我们从安迪开始。好吧。
Andy walks over to the water. And we had a fan question about this from Allie Joe Higginbotham, who said, when Andy walks to the lake, he has something yellow in his hands. And what is he holding? And what is he planning to do with it at the shore? Well, he's holding a... A bandana. He's holding a yellow bandana.
安迪走到水边。我们有一个关于这个的粉丝提问，来自艾莉·乔·希金博瑟姆，她说，当安迪走到湖边时，他手里拿着黄色的东西。他拿着什么？他打算在岸边用它做什么？嗯，他拿着一个……头巾。他拿着一个黄色头巾。
Michael had handed these out in the egg race. And that's what everyone had used to cover their eyes. And Andy is holding his yellow bandana from the egg race. And he hopes to dip it in the water to then maybe wrap it around his neck to cool himself off. This was the idea. Yes. But instead, he falls in the water and starts floating away. When he fell in the water, you know, I wasn't too far off because my character witnesses this.
迈克尔在鸡蛋赛跑中分发了这些。每个人都用它来遮住眼睛。安迪拿着他从鸡蛋赛跑中得到的黄色头巾。他希望把它蘸在水里，然后也许把它围在脖子上给自己降温。这就是主意。是的。但相反，他掉进水里，开始漂走。当他掉进水里时，你知道，我离得不远，因为我的角色目睹了这一切。
Yes. And there's a take that didn't make it that he literally went, he like rolled, Jenna, he like rolled into the water. But they used this take because it was more clear why he was going down there. He's trying to hang that bandana in the water, trying to balance. Well, let me say, and we got another frequently asked question. from Candice Kelso, Michael Lung, Olive Taylor, and Phoebe Bono, was that really Ed in the water? Was that a stunt double? Guys, that was Ed in the water.
是的。有一个没被放进去的镜头，他真的去了，他像翻滚一样，珍娜，他像翻滚进水里。但他们用了这个镜头，因为更清楚他为什么要下到那里。他试图把那个头巾挂在水里，试图保持平衡。好吧，让我说，我们收到了另一个常见问题。来自坎迪斯·凯尔索、迈克尔·朗、奥利夫·泰勒和菲比·博诺，那是艾德在水里吗？那是替身吗？伙计们，那是艾德在水里。
Ed did it all. I don't know that they offered him a stunt double. I don't know. Kent told me they offered him a stunt double, but Ed insisted on doing all of the floating in the water himself. He was out there floating for over 45 minutes. minutes. And I'm thinking maybe when he was like, oh, no, I'll fall in the water. Like, maybe he didn't realize what that all entailed. Yeah. And perhaps having a stunt double on the side to complete some of the very far away floating. But guys, that is Ed the whole time floating out there. Not only in the
艾德做了这一切。我不知道他们是否给他提供了替身。我不知道。肯告诉我他们给他提供了替身，但艾德坚持要自己完成所有的漂浮。他在外面漂了超过45分钟。分钟。我在想也许当他像，哦，不，我会掉进水里。就像，也许他没意识到那意味着什么。是的。也许在旁边有一个替身来完成一些非常遥远的漂浮。但伙计们，那是艾德全程漂在那里。不仅在
day, but then he had to do it again at night. This was two different. shoots for him in the water, a day scene and a night scene. Now, when he was out there at night, he did have a thin wet suit on underneath all that sumo gear to keep him warm. So they did think of that. But before we get too far into this stunt, Angela, we also had fan questions from Rebecca Gonzalez, Connor N, and Mora Anderson, who said, Angela, how did you make it through the scene of Andy floating away?
天，但他必须在晚上再拍一次。对他来说，这是在水里的两场不同的拍摄，一场日戏和一场夜戏。当他在晚上拍摄时，他在相扑服下面穿了一件薄潜水服来保暖。所以他们确实考虑到了这一点。但在我们深入探讨这个特技之前，安吉拉，我们还收到了来自丽贝卡·冈萨雷斯、康纳·N和莫拉·安德森的粉丝提问，他们问：安吉拉，你是怎么熬过安迪漂走的那场戏的？
it was so hard it was that's what she said oh boy i'm sorry it was really i'm sorry it was really difficult difficult not to laugh really difficult especially because ed was improvising a little bit as he floated away some of that dialogue was not scripted so you know when i'm like i don't really understand what it is you're saying to me that was scripted but then ed ed was physically away and he was dealing with the elements and he improvised this line. Look at what I'm doing and go tell somebody it. I love that line so much. That was Ed improvising. That is awesome. I know. So it was really hard. And I didn't want to laugh because poor Ed is floating out in that water. You know what I mean? Yes. If you laugh, you ruin that moment and he has to float longer. I was working hard. I was working hard. I was working hard.
太难了，她就是这么说的，天哪，我很抱歉，这真的，我很抱歉，这真的很难，很难不笑，真的很难，尤其是因为埃德在漂走的时候即兴发挥了一些，有些台词并没有写在剧本里，所以你知道，当我说我真的不明白你在对我说什么时，那是剧本写的，但后来埃德，埃德在身体上漂走了，他在应对各种自然因素，他即兴说了这句台词。看看我在做什么，去告诉别人。我太喜欢那句台词了。那是埃德即兴发挥的。太棒了。我知道。所以这真的很难。我不想笑，因为可怜的埃德正漂在那片水域里。你明白我的意思吗？是的。如果你笑了，你就毁了那一刻，他必须漂得更久。我当时很努力。我当时很努力。我当时很努力。
to laugh. Well, we asked Jen about Ed in the water, and here's what she had to say. Oh, shooting the Andy Floating Away scenes was really fun. I love that part of the script. I love when Angela pretends that she doesn't understand what he's saying. That was so much fun to write. I remember that Ed was like in the sumo suit, and then there was a rope attached to him, and he was being pulled by a boat and then at a certain point the boat would leave him and then he would just drift
不笑。好吧，我们问了简关于埃德在水里的情况，她是这么说的。哦，拍摄安迪漂走的那几场戏真的很有趣。我喜欢剧本的那一部分。我喜欢安吉拉假装听不懂他在说什么的样子。写那段戏太有趣了。我记得埃德穿着相扑服，然后有一根绳子系在他身上，他被一艘船拉着，然后在某个时刻，船会离开他，然后他就会漂走
but there was also a current I believe the water was also cold and he had to keep his head up and I remember that it was a challenging thing because his head would sort of get lost and it would just like go under unless he helped he put his neck up and just try to hold it up
但当时还有水流，我相信水也很冷，他必须保持头部抬起，我记得这是一件很有挑战性的事情，因为他的头会有点迷失方向，如果不帮忙的话，他就会沉下去，所以他必须把脖子抬起来，尽量保持头部不沉下去
so I think it was a difficult thing also the timing of the boat and the timing of us trying to get it on camera with Michael's talking head was difficult. So I remember that Ed was like a real trooper and there were a lot of discussions about like how far out he should be at sea because we wanted to see him. We didn't want to be too obvious that it was him and Michael might see him, but we didn't want him to be so far away that he was this tiny little dot. So Ed was in the water for quite a while while we tried to work this out. And the other thing I remember, which is crazy
所以我认为这是一件困难的事情，而且船的时间安排以及我们试图用迈克尔的谈话头镜头拍摄的时间安排也很困难。所以我记得埃德表现得非常坚强，关于他应该在海上漂多远有很多讨论，因为我们想看到他。我们不想太明显地看出那是他，迈克尔可能会看到他，但我们也不想让他离得太远，以至于他只是一个小点。所以当我们试图解决这个问题时，埃德在水里待了很长时间。我记得的另一件事，这很疯狂
to say now, but there was a safety meeting right before it. And I, I feel like at the very beginning of the safety meeting, like Ed was there, but like he was just getting there because everything was so rushed. And I think the safety person said one thing, like as Ed was approaching that I wasn't sure Ed clocked and I had this moment of should I tell him or not. And I remember the safety guy talking about water snakes. And I was like, oh my God, oh my God. Do I repeat this to Ed? Do I not repeat this? I don't think I repeated it to Ed because like he was going to be in this.
现在说起来，但在拍摄前有一个安全会议。我觉得在安全会议刚开始的时候，埃德在那里，但他只是刚到，因为一切都太匆忙了。我想安全人员在埃德走近时说了一件事，我不确定埃德是否注意到了，我当时在想，我该不该告诉他？我记得安全人员提到了水蛇。我当时想，天哪，天哪。我要不要告诉埃德？我要不要重复一遍？我想我没有告诉埃德，因为他马上就要下水了。
water. It was going to be very cold. I thought, would I want to know about water snakes before I got into the water in a sumo suit or not? So yeah, I think I made that decision. Tell me if you think that was the correct decision to make. Anyway, so there were a lot of challenges of shooting that. There were no snake events during the shooting of that sequence. And I thought Ed did a phenomenal job. And so did Angela. And I'm just in love with that sequence. of events, but it was challenging to shoot. Wow. Ed.
水里。水会非常冷。我想，在穿上相扑服下水之前，我想知道关于水蛇的事吗？所以是的，我想我做了那个决定。告诉我你认为这是不是正确的决定。总之，拍摄那场戏有很多挑战。在拍摄那个序列期间没有发生蛇的事件。我认为埃德做得非常出色。安吉拉也是。我非常喜欢那个事件序列，但拍摄起来确实很有挑战性。哇。埃德。
Ed. Possibility of water snakes. Oh, my God. Oh, boy. Jen Salada. Well, now Jen mentioned in her clip that they would have to pull Ed behind a boat to get him in place. So Kent told me that power boats were not allowed on the lake. So they had to have a stunt coordinator in a rowboat.
埃德。有水蛇的可能性。天哪。天哪。简·萨拉达。好吧，现在简在她的片段中提到他们必须用船拉着埃德才能让他到位。所以肯告诉我，湖上不允许使用动力船。所以他们必须让一个特技协调员划着小船。
I remember, Jenna. I remember the rowing him. Can you imagine if you're somewhere else at this park and you're just hiking or maybe you're riding a horse from the equestrian center and you look out onto the lake and you see a man in a rowboat rowing another man by a rope who's in a sumo suit? What are you thinking when you see that? I don't know. What goes to your head? I don't know. Are you worried? What are you thinking?
我记得，珍娜。我记得划船送他。你能想象如果你在公园的其他地方，你只是在徒步旅行，或者也许你正骑着马从马术中心出来，你望向湖面，看到一个男人划着小船，用绳子拉着另一个穿着相扑服的男人？当你看到这个时，你在想什么？我不知道。你脑子里在想什么？我不知道。你担心吗？你在想什么？
So I watched this play out because we would have to reset Ed to that spot where we would have dialogue. And inevitably, he'd float away, right? And then they would, the guy, there he was. And I had to make sure I didn't look at the rowboat guy, right? You know, like I couldn't have my eyes dart away. But off in the periphery of my vision was this guy in a boat. and he would row and pull Ed. Ed had a harness suit on under the sumo suit. And they put through the arm of the sumo suit a fishing line. Yeah. And this guy would pull Ed. And as he did, Jenna, I would see water break around his body. You know, like if you hold something in the water.
所以我看着这一切发生，因为我们必须把埃德重置到我们有对话的那个位置。不可避免地，他会漂走，对吧？然后他们会，那个人，他就在那里。我必须确保我不看划船的那个人，对吧？你知道，我的眼睛不能乱瞟。但在我的余光里，有这个人在船上。他会划船并拉着埃德。埃德在相扑服下穿了一件背带服。他们在相扑服的袖子里穿了一根钓鱼线。是的。这个人会拉着埃德。当他这样做时，珍娜，我会看到水在他的身体周围破开。你知道，就像如果你在水里拿着什么东西一样。
Yeah. And Ed said that a majority of that water is he was. being pulled would flush through the suit and out his neck. Well, Kent told me if you look carefully in the Michael talking head where Ed is floating in the background, you will see that there's a pretty strong current in the water. But Ed is not moving. That is because at that point, the only way to keep him in the shot was to just keep him attached to the boat. And so he said, if you look for it, he's very oddly staying in one place while a pretty heavy current is going underneath him.
是的。埃德说，当他被拉着时，大部分水会冲进衣服里，然后从他的脖子处流出来。好吧，肯告诉我，如果你仔细看迈克尔的谈话头镜头，埃德在背景中漂浮，你会看到水里有相当强的水流。但埃德没有动。这是因为在那一点上，让他留在镜头里的唯一方法就是让他一直系在船上。所以他说，如果你仔细看，他非常奇怪地停在一个地方，而相当大的水流在他身下流过。
So, so insane. Angela, I also got the story about these sumo suits from Carrie Bennett, our wardrobe designer. Oh, let's hear it. So she said that this was one of the most difficult costume challenges she had for our show. She had to create these inflatable sumo suits, but because she knew Andy would end up floating away in it, whatever she put them in had to be safe for him to float on water. So she said, as soon as she read the script, she immediately went to Greg and said, I cannot design a costume that will allow someone to float on water. I need a stunt person to help me. So she got together with
太，太疯狂了。安吉拉，我还从我们的服装设计师凯莉·贝内特那里听到了关于这些相扑服的故事。哦，让我们听听。她说这是她为我们的节目面临的最困难的服装挑战之一。她必须制作这些充气相扑服，但因为她知道安迪最终会穿着它漂走，所以无论她给他们穿什么，都必须确保他在水上漂浮是安全的。所以她说，她一读到剧本，就立刻去找格雷格说，我无法设计出一套能让人在水上漂浮的服装。我需要一个特技演员来帮我。所以她和
the stunt person, and they realized that kind of like what Jen said, the biggest challenge was keeping his head from going underwater, because she was like, his body would float, but the head would go under. So that is why the guys are wearing those crazy head pieces in the episode. Those were custom made, right? Yes. Yeah. She said, what if I made a floaty helmet in the shape of like a sumo wrestler's bun. And the bun is actually a floating device. Brilliant. So she designed this extra bit of safety for Ed with this floaty bun. And before we shot, they went over to Kent Sabornak's pool and they put a stunt guy in the suit and they tested it out. And it worked. Oh my gosh. You're talking about what happens when like someone's riding a horse by and Ed's floating and there's a
特技演员聚在一起，他们意识到就像简说的那样，最大的挑战是防止他的头沉入水下，因为她说，他的身体会漂浮，但头会沉下去。这就是为什么剧中的男人们戴着那些奇怪的头饰。那些是定制的，对吧？是的。是的。她说，如果我做一个相扑选手发髻形状的浮力头盔呢？那个发髻实际上是一个漂浮装置。太聪明了。所以她为埃德设计了这个额外的安全装置，带有这个浮力发髻。在拍摄之前，他们去了肯·萨博纳克的游泳池，他们让一个特技演员穿上这套衣服并进行了测试。它成功了。天哪。你在说当有人骑马经过，埃德在漂浮，而有一个
with a rowboat. What about Kent's family? Hey, dad, what's, who's in the pool? Don't worry about it. It's a little thing for work. Totally. Totally. Also, when these guys in the writer's room wrote this sequence, they had no idea the paces that they would put people through to make it realized on screen. It was just a funny idea. Oh, you know what would be? funny, they wrestle in these sumo suits and then Ed falls in the water and floats away. I mean, the amount of effort that went into making that happen. I know. I think about this all the time with our scripts. Like, oh, it'll be funny. We'll have a funeral for a bird. But we need a specialized tiny coffin made. Yeah. And several dead birds to
划着小船。肯的家人呢？嘿，爸爸，游泳池里是谁？别担心。这是工作的一点小事。完全是。完全是。另外，当编剧室的这些人写这个序列时，他们根本不知道为了在屏幕上实现它，他们会让人经历什么样的折磨。这只是一个有趣的想法。哦，你知道什么会很有趣吗？他们在相扑服里摔跤，然后埃德掉进水里漂走了。我的意思是，为了实现这一点所付出的努力。我知道。我总是想到我们的剧本。比如，哦，那会很有趣。我们要为一只鸟举行葬礼。但我们需要一个专门制作的小棺材。是的。还有几只死鸟可以
choose from. And then Jim and Karen sneak off and they're sneaking off to call David. But Pam doesn't know that, but you know she saw them walk away. You know she did. She's aware. Yeah. And they have this moment where they, you know, call David. Jim says he wants to be considered. And then Karen does. And then Jim is like teasing her because she sort of fumbles her words, right?
挑选。然后吉姆和凯伦溜走了，他们溜走去给大卫打电话。但帕姆不知道，但你知道她看到他们走开了。你知道她看到了。她意识到了。是的。他们有这一刻，你知道，他们给大卫打电话。吉姆说他想被考虑。然后凯伦也说了。然后吉姆在逗她，因为她说话有点结巴，对吧？
When she calls David. Yeah. I didn't think that was cool boyfriend behavior, I have to say. Oh, right. Because she's trying to leave a professional message, right? She's speaking to David Wallace. And she's saying she'd like to be considered for this job. and he's kind of heckling her during this phone call.
当她给大卫打电话时。是的。我不得不说，我不认为那是很酷的男朋友行为。哦，对。因为她正试图留下一个专业的口信，对吧？她正在和大卫·华莱士说话。她说她想被考虑担任这个职位。而他在这个电话过程中一直在嘲讽她。
And he's distracting her. And I know I think it was meant to be kind of like cute and playful. But I don't know. If I'm making a professional phone call, I don't appreciate being heckled. Don't mess with me. Don't mess with me when I'm making an important boss lady call. Or is he trying to sabotage? he might be trying to sandwich this moment he tried to sandwich it well we also mentioned earlier that
他在分散她的注意力。我知道我认为这本意是想表现得可爱和俏皮。但我不知道。如果我正在打一个重要的职业电话，我不喜欢被嘲讽。别惹我。当我打一个重要的女老板电话时，别惹我。还是他在试图破坏？他可能在试图破坏这一刻，他试图破坏它。好吧，我们之前也提到过
this was an added scene originally these phone calls happened in the office before we went to beach day but they made a change and they decided it was better to reveal this information later but this led to problems like we already had such a pack day and here we were trying to add little moments and add little scenes. And Jen actually talked about this as one of the challenges, just trying to get everything shot on these days. Because, you know, you have so many things you have to shoot in daylight. And then the sun goes down.
这是一个增加的场景，最初这些电话是在我们去海滩日之前在办公室打的，但他们做了一个改变，他们认为最好晚点揭示这些信息。但这导致了问题，比如我们已经有了一个如此紧凑的一天，而我们在这里试图增加一些小瞬间和增加一些小场景。简实际上谈到了这是挑战之一，只是试图在这些日子里完成所有拍摄。因为，你知道，你必须在白天拍摄很多东西。然后太阳下山了。
You can't make it stay out. Also, these were such big ambitious days. And if we would go past the allotted time, we would get into overtime, which was incredibly expensive for the show because they would have to pay the crew overtime, the actors over time. And so Kent Sabornak, our line producer, was trying to keep us on our day. And he was having to check in with Jen and Harold quite a bit about it. Yeah. Here's what she had to say about that.
你无法让太阳不落山。此外，这些都是非常宏大且雄心勃勃的日子。如果我们超过了分配的时间，我们就会进入加班，这对节目来说非常昂贵，因为他们必须支付剧组加班费，演员加班费。所以我们的制片经理肯·萨博纳克试图让我们按计划进行。他不得不经常和简以及哈罗德核对这件事。是的。这是她对此的看法。
And I remember Kent being very patient with us and giving us extra time and adding in cushions, but it was still really difficult to get everything that we needed to get done. I mean, we were going very fast and working incredibly efficiently. It was just hard. And I remember there was one moment where Kent had already. given us a cushion and maybe even a second cushion and then we were about to go over it by we were almost done we were so close to being done but kent called and i got the call and we were about ready to say you know herald was about ready to call action and kent is like frustrated because he
我记得肯对我们非常有耐心，给了我们额外的时间并增加了缓冲，但要完成我们需要做的一切仍然非常困难。我的意思是，我们进行得非常快，工作效率极高。这只是很难。我记得有一次肯已经给了我们一个缓冲，甚至可能是第二个缓冲，然后我们就要超过它了，我们快完成了，我们离完成非常近，但肯打了电话，我接到了电话，我们准备说，你知道哈罗德准备喊开始，而肯很沮丧，因为他
wants us to be done because he's given us extra time and he wants us to be done and completely understandable. But I knew that if I kept talking to Kent, we were going to be slowed down by 10 seconds at that point, and that 10 seconds would allow us to finish the shot. So Ken is talking to me and I very gently and gingerly just put the phone down on a chair and we got the last shot and we were done. It was definitely this weird moment of like, this is the producer of your show telling you that you need to stop shooting. And I realized, I can either talk to him about the fact that we're going to stop shooting or get the shot. So we got the shot.
希望我们完成，因为他给了我们额外的时间，他希望我们完成，这完全可以理解。但我知道如果我继续和肯说话，我们当时会被拖慢10秒，而那10秒将允许我们完成拍摄。所以肯在和我说话，我非常温柔地把电话放在椅子上，我们完成了最后一次拍摄，我们就完成了。这绝对是一个奇怪的时刻，就像，这是你的节目的制片人在告诉你你需要停止拍摄。我意识到，我可以和他谈论我们要停止拍摄的事实，或者完成拍摄。所以我们完成了拍摄。
It was definitely one of those moments of like, ha, hope that was cool. Angela, I think that what Jen is talking about is a little bit of sabotage. Is she sabotaging? She's not sabotaging. She's sabotaging her phone call so that they could get these shots. I think it's pretty amazing. Like, I can sort of just visualize Kent going on and on, like, Jen, you can't keep adding scenes. And she just set the phone down and was like, yes, do it one more time.
这绝对是那种时刻，就像，哈，希望那很酷。安吉拉，我认为简所说的是一点点破坏。她在破坏吗？她没有在破坏。她是在破坏她的电话，以便他们能完成这些拍摄。我认为这很了不起。就像，我可以想象肯一直在说，简，你不能一直增加场景。而她只是放下电话，就像，是的，再做一次。
One more time while he's venting. Yes, exactly. Well, you guys, part of Kent's job, he has such a hard job because he answers to both Greg, who is the creative voice of the show. And, you know, his job is to make all of Greg's dreams come true creatively. But he also answers to the network who has given him a budget. budget and a timetable and you can't spend more money than this and everything that you said earlier, Angela, about staying on time because Kent will look at a script and he will try to estimate based on conversations with the director and the writer and the crew, how long each scene will take. So he'll say, all right, we need three hours to film Ed at C. But I'm only going to give 45 minutes to Jim and Karen in the sand. That's right. And if any of these things go over even 10 minutes,
再做一次，当他在发泄时。是的，完全正确。好吧，伙计们，肯的工作的一部分，他的工作非常困难，因为他要对格雷格负责，格雷格是节目的创意声音。而且，你知道，他的工作是让格雷格所有的梦想在创意上成真。但他也要对网络负责，网络给了他预算和时间表，你不能花比这更多的钱，而且你之前说的所有关于准时的事情，安吉拉，因为肯会看剧本，他会尝试根据与导演、编剧和剧组的谈话来估计每个场景需要多长时间。所以他会说，好吧，我们需要三个小时来拍摄埃德在海上的戏。但我只给吉姆和凯伦在沙滩上的戏45分钟。没错。如果这些事情中任何一个超过了哪怕10分钟，
they have to steal 10 minutes from another scene. And it becomes just this logistical nightmare. And Kent has to keep an eye on all of it. And it is a vicious domino effect, too. Once you get off, it just spirals your whole day. I feel like this is like a great metaphor for partnerships, because I feel like in every family, there's one person that's a little bit of the big thinker dreamer.
他们就必须从另一个场景中偷走10分钟。这变成了一个后勤噩梦。肯必须密切关注这一切。这也会产生恶性的多米诺骨牌效应。一旦你偏离了轨道，你的一整天就会陷入混乱。我觉得这就像是伙伴关系的一个很好的隐喻，因为我觉得在每个家庭里，都有一个人是那种有点大思想的梦想家。
On vacation, we'll do all of this. And then there's the person in the relationship that's like, I've allotted $80 for things at the gift shop. That's all we're spending at the gift shop, okay? Because if we spend more than $80 at the gift shop, we can't do that extra bungee cord thing that you all want to do. Yes. That is exactly Kent. He is that person.
在度假时，我们会做所有这些。然后关系中还有一个人是那种，我已经为礼品店的东西分配了80美元。我们在礼品店只花这么多，好吗？因为如果我们花超过80美元在礼品店，我们就不能做你们都想做的那个额外的蹦极项目了。是的。那正是肯。他就是那个人。
Keep us on budget. Keep us on time. Yep. Well, now, Angela, it is time for the coal walk. Talk about a big scene. This was a big evening for us. It was a very ambitious shoot. We had a lot to cover.
让我们保持在预算内。让我们按时完成。是的。好吧，现在，安吉拉，是时候走煤炭了。谈谈一个大场景。这对我们来说是一个重要的夜晚。这是一个非常有野心的拍摄。我们有很多内容要涵盖。
We could not start until it got dark. Yep. And there was a lot of prep. I don't know if you remember, Jenna, how they made those coals. Do you remember? I do. It was multi-layered. And we had a lot of people ask this question about how did you make the coals?
我们直到天黑才能开始。是的。而且有很多准备工作。我不知道你是否记得，珍娜，他们是怎么制作那些煤炭的。你记得吗？我记得。它是多层的。我们有很多人问这个问题，关于你们是怎么制作煤炭的？
We got mail from Ellie Troutman, Chandra M., Jamie S., Heather Donnelly, Renee R, and many others. they wanted to know how did the props department create the hot coals they looked so real because guys these were not real coals yes so we could not have a huge fire here you guys we were allowed to have the teaky torches
我们收到了来自Ellie Troutman、Chandra M.、Jamie S.、Heather Donnelly、Renee R以及许多其他人的来信。他们想知道道具部门是如何制作那些看起来如此真实的炽热煤炭的，因为伙计们，这些根本不是真的煤炭。是的，我们不能在这里生大火，伙计们，我们只被允许使用火把
and little small flames for example when the pile of wood burst into flames that's all special effects that was not at all a fire they put that in in post because there were fire regulations at this particular park
和一些小火焰。例如，当那堆木头突然起火时，那全是特效，根本不是真正的火。他们是在后期制作中加入的，因为这个特定的公园有消防规定。
right Well, there are fire regulations in California in general. Yes, yes, absolutely. So Harold Ramos talked a little bit about this coal fire pit on the DVD commentary. He said they started, first of all, by digging a big hole in the ground. And then they buried in the ground a light box, just a big box that lit up. And then they put on top of the light box these little yellow and orange, gels to make it look like a flame. And then on top of those light gels, on top of the
没错。嗯，加州总的来说是有消防规定的。是的，是的，绝对是。所以Harold Ramos在DVD评论中谈到了一些关于这个煤火坑的事情。他说，首先，他们从在地上挖一个大洞开始。然后他们在地下埋了一个灯箱，就是一个会发光的大盒子。接着，他们在灯箱上面放了一些黄色和橙色的凝胶，让它看起来像火焰。然后，在这些灯光凝胶上面，在
light box, they put little lava rocks. And then running on either side of this hole in the ground, they had put two gas lines with very small little flickers of real fire that popped out of the ground. Yes. And because there was real fire as part of the coal walk, we had a very big safety. meeting about that. One of our biggest. Yeah, for sure. It's particularly important because, as you know, Rain, as Dwight, is going to walk onto these hot coals, stand there, and then follow the ground. And that was real fire next to him. On either side of him, yes. And I remember when Rain did that, one of the most painful things for Rain was being barefoot on the lava rocks. It heard it. It's like, it's like stepping on a Lego. You know how that feels.
灯箱上面，他们放了些小熔岩石。然后，在地上这个洞的两侧，他们放置了两条燃气管道，会有非常微小的真实火焰从地里冒出来。是的。而且因为煤炭行走的一部分确实有真实的火，我们为此开了一个非常重要的安全会议。这是我们最重要的会议之一。是的，当然。这特别重要，因为如你所知，Rain饰演的Dwight要走上这些炽热的煤炭，站在那里，然后倒在地上。而他旁边就是真实的火。是的，在他两侧。我记得Rain做那个动作时，对他来说最痛苦的事情之一就是赤脚踩在熔岩石上。那很疼。就像踩在乐高积木上一样。你知道那种感觉。
I do know how it feels because I did it as well. Yeah. In fact, I'll say that people have mentioned that I look like my feet really hurt after I walk across the hot coals and they've wondered if I really walked on hot coals. No, my feet were sore and bruised from having to run across lava rocks over and over again. Yeah. Like, my feet did kind of hurt. Throw a bunch of like hard Legos on the ground and run back and forth over them. That's as good as a coal walk right there.
我确实知道那种感觉，因为我也试过。是的。事实上，我会说人们提到过，我走过炽热的煤炭后，脚看起来真的很疼，他们想知道我是不是真的走在炽热的煤炭上。不，我的脚是因为不得不一次又一次地跑过熔岩石而感到酸痛和淤青。是的。就像，我的脚确实有点疼。在地上扔一堆硬乐高积木，然后来回跑。那和煤炭行走的效果是一样的。
a Lego walk. If you want that experience, you can do it at home. Michael wanted everyone to walk over the hot coals. We said he has to go first. And Steve's hesitation as Michael to go over those coals, Jenna, was so brilliant. His whole body posture, the expression on his face. And he improvised the line, the mind has to wrap around the foot. I love that that was an improvisation.
乐高行走。如果你想要那种体验，你在家就能做到。Michael想让每个人都走过炽热的煤炭。我们说他必须先走。Jenna，Steve作为Michael在走过那些煤炭时的犹豫真是太精彩了。他整个身体的姿势，他脸上的表情。而且他即兴发挥了一句台词，“思想必须包裹住脚”。我喜欢那是即兴创作的。
And I did not look that up. I love knowing that. And we have a call back to this whole runner of Angela being grossed out by Kevin's feet. Yes. She's like, I am not going to go after you and your gross feet. And he's like, Angela, it's like a thousand degrees. One of my favorite moments in this whole sequence is when Michael says to the group, he's so disappointed that no one has walked across the coals except sort of
我没有去查过。我很高兴知道这一点。我们还有一个关于Angela被Kevin的脚恶心到的情节的回应。是的。她说，我才不要跟在你和你那恶心的脚后面。他说，Angela，这有一千度呢。在这个序列中，我最喜欢的时刻之一是Michael对大家说，他很失望，除了Dwight之外，没有人走过煤炭，
Dwight. And he says, you know what? It's clear to me that if I had to name my replacement today, it would be Mr. Outside Higher. And then Angela says, or Mrs. Outside Higher, and Michael is like, yes, or that. He's so condescending. It made me laugh so hard. I know, but a little bit of Angela sass there. Like I pointed my fingers. Yeah. Wait, Jenna. We do have a background catch. We can't pass up. It's too good. Say it.
他说，你知道吗？我很清楚，如果我今天必须提名我的继任者，那会是那位“外部招聘先生”。然后Angela说，或者“外部招聘女士”，Michael就说，是的，或者那个。他太傲慢了。这让我笑得很大声。我知道，但Angela那里有一点点傲慢。就像我指着我的手指一样。是的。等等，Jenna。我们有一个背景细节不能错过。太棒了。说吧。
While Michael's going on and on about who won't walk across the coals and he's like, and Andy is never here today, it pans past us to the water. Andy has floated into the marsh. He's stuck on his back. Poor Ed in the dark, in the lake. And at 19 minutes, 55 seconds, you can see his wetsuit on his arm. Oh. Yeah, on his arm.
当Michael喋喋不休地说谁不肯走过煤炭时，他说，Andy今天根本没来，镜头扫过我们看向水面。Andy漂进了沼泽。他背朝上卡住了。可怜的Ed在黑暗的湖里。在19分55秒时，你可以看到他手臂上的潜水服。哦。是的，在他的手臂上。
His arm is like extended out of his sumo suit. And you can see the beige wet suit that he had to put on because it was so cold. And then people wrote in, Angela, and they said, how come in season nine when Pam is crying, the documentary crew helps her? But when Andy is floating away at night, they just turn off the camera lights and walk away. I know. I know. That's one of the questions Jack had my stepson. He was like, why did the camera crew not help him? I know. And I was like, you know what? At that moment, they were like, we can't disturb the natural course of the story. We must just document it. Well, we're coming up to this big moment. There is a huge moment about to happen for Pam.
他的手臂像是从相扑服里伸出来的。你可以看到他不得不穿上的米色潜水服，因为当时太冷了。然后人们写信来问，Angela，他们说，为什么在第九季Pam哭的时候，纪录片摄制组会帮助她？但当Andy在晚上漂走时，他们只是关掉摄像机灯光就走开了。我知道。我知道。这是我继子Jack问的问题之一。他问，为什么摄制组不帮他？我知道。我说，你知道吗？在那一刻，他们觉得，我们不能干扰故事的自然进程。我们必须记录下来。好吧，我们即将迎来这个重要的时刻。Pam即将迎来一个巨大的时刻。
Yeah. She wants to run across the coals and Michael says no. No. Yeah. And then he moves them on and he wants them all to speak. Dwight is doing his version of the aristocrats very badly. And in the background, Pam runs across the coals. Yeah. And this just feeds her soul. She feels so alive in this moment. She did this one thing for herself. And she runs over to the group and she wants to share. Yeah. And she gives this speech. And everything just comes pouring out. Her disappointment that people didn't come to the art show. But more than that, her feelings for Jim and how much she misses him.
是的。她想跑过煤炭，但Michael说不行。不行。是的。然后他让他们继续前进，并希望他们每个人都发言。Dwight正在非常糟糕地表演他的“贵族”版本。而在背景中，Pam跑过了煤炭。是的。这滋养了她的灵魂。她在这一刻感到如此鲜活。她为自己做了这一件事。她跑向人群，想要分享。是的。她发表了这段演讲。一切都倾泻而出。她对人们没有参加艺术展的失望。但更重要的是，她对Jim的感情，以及她有多想念他。
And the truth, the big truth, which is that while there were many reasons to call off her wedding to Roy, the reason she did it was because of how she feels about Jim. Yeah. And, oof, first of all. all, I sat next to John in this scene. Angel and Jim are side by side. I don't know if you noticed that. I did. And so when you were talking to Jim, I was right in your eye line. You know, I couldn't believe my luck, honestly, because this is such a beautiful performance by you, Jenna. You do such a great job. It's so moving to watch you as Pam transition through all of those beats. and I had this out-of-body experience as your friend watching you in awe
还有真相，那个巨大的真相，那就是虽然她取消与Roy的婚礼有很多原因，但她这样做的原因是因为她对Jim的感受。是的。而且，哎呀，首先。我在这场戏里坐在John旁边。Angela和Jim并排坐着。不知道你有没有注意到。我注意到了。所以当你和Jim说话时，我就在你的视线范围内。说实话，我简直不敢相信我的运气，因为这是你非常精彩的表演，Jenna。你做得太棒了。看着Pam经历所有这些情绪起伏，真是太感人了。作为你的朋友，我有一种灵魂出窍的体验，敬畏地看着你
give this fantastic performance wanting to tear up and cry because my friend was crushing it and then having to be Angela Martin who would never react to you that way and then at the same time just being in awe of this moment it was it was just a beautiful thing to watch, Jenna, you did such a great job, and you had to do it over and over. We did several takes because they had to get people's reactions, and every time you crushed it, every single time. Well, a lot of people ask if that speech was improvised or partially improvised, and it was not. That was all written, and as Jen shared with us, written by Greg Daniels, and I memorized it
呈现出如此精彩的表演，想流泪，因为我的朋友表现得太棒了，然后又不得不扮演那个永远不会那样回应你的Angela Martin，同时又对这一刻感到敬畏，这真是太美好了，Jenna，你做得太棒了，而且你不得不一遍又一遍地做。我们拍了好几次，因为他们必须捕捉人们的反应，而每一次你都表现得非常出色，每一次都是。嗯，很多人问那段演讲是即兴的还是部分即兴的，其实不是。那全是写好的，正如Jen和我们分享的那样，是由Greg Daniels写的，我把它背了下来
and delivered it word for word. I worked on it for a very long time, and I remember, I remember trying to think about those times in my life where you've done something that give you a burst of adrenaline. And that's what I wanted her to come into the speech with. She's just done this coal walk, and she has this burst of adrenaline, and she doesn't even think about that she's going to share. It's completely different. This is very impulsive and that was that was kind of what I put behind the speech. But I knew that speech backwards and forwards. I could have delivered it for days because I also know as an actor, at least for me, especially, the more I
并逐字逐句地表达出来。我为此准备了很长时间，我记得，我记得试图回想我生命中那些让你肾上腺素激增的时刻。这就是我想要她带着那种感觉进入演讲的原因。她刚刚完成了煤炭行走，她有一种肾上腺素的爆发，她甚至没想过她会分享这些。这完全不同。这是非常冲动的，这就是我赋予这段演讲的背景。但我对那段演讲倒背如流。我可以连续几天把它背出来，因为我也知道作为一名演员，至少对我来说，尤其是，我越
know the material, the less I have to think of the word. Exactly. And it can just be about the performance. I was, I never had to search for it. I had it. It was like on a little tape in my head. That's exactly right. You don't have to worry about what you're saying and you can just really experience the moment and feel it because the words are all there. And I just thought it was brilliant. And I thought everyone's reactions were great because there's, there is a dance that you do on a show like the office. There is the person who is driving the scene who's putting out all this information. And then the other side of the story is the people reacting to it. And the two parts are very important. And I thought that John is Jim, his reactions were great. Everyone in the
了解剧本，我就越不需要去想词。没错。这样就可以专注于表演。我从来不需要去搜索台词。我记住了。它就像我脑子里的一盘小磁带。完全正确。你不需要担心你在说什么，你可以真正体验那一刻并感受它，因为台词都在那里。我觉得这太精彩了。而且我觉得每个人的反应都很棒，因为在像《办公室》这样的节目里，有一种舞蹈。有一个人是推动场景发展的，他输出了所有这些信息。而故事的另一面是人们对它的反应。这两个部分都非常重要。我觉得John饰演的Jim，他的反应很棒。人群中的每个人
crowd they cut to Rashida. Oh my God. Her look as Karen was amazing. It was like, I can't believe this is happening. Oh my God. It was everything. And also heartbreak. It was all of it. Yeah. Well, and you mentioned. about what it's like to be the person driving a scene, this was kind of my first experience with that. And it was this huge speech. And that's another reason why I made sure I knew every single word. And I got a real glimpse at what Steve does every single day, every single week.
他们切到了Rashida。天哪。她作为Karen的表情太惊人了。就像是，我不敢相信这正在发生。天哪。那是一切。还有心碎。全都有了。是的。嗯，你提到了作为推动场景的人是什么感觉，这算是我第一次有这种体验。这是一段巨大的演讲。这也是我确保自己知道每一个字的原因。我真正瞥见了Steve每天、每周都在做的事情。
Wow. Delivering these big speeches to the group. I mean, all your eyeballs were on me. I was so nervous. Yeah, it's a lot of work. It's a lot of work. And not just the cast. watching you. The whole crew, it's everything. Yeah. Well, I thought it was so great. I just loved it so
哇。向团队发表这些大演讲。我的意思是，所有的目光都盯着我。我太紧张了。是的，这工作量很大。这工作量很大。而且不仅仅是演员在看着你。整个剧组，一切都是。是的。嗯，我觉得这太棒了。我太喜欢它了，所以
much. Well, thank you. You know, I hadn't seen it since it first aired. And when I watched it, I was really proud of myself. You should be. I was like, oh my gosh, I love that that performance is on tape and I can watch it later because it really made me feel like a good actress. I was like, oh, look at me go. You are a good actress. I was so proud of myself. You should feel that way. You should. Well, I was always, I was always curious why they sat me next to Jim and didn't have Karen next to him. And then that moment ends with Jim looking straight ahead and me kind of looking off to the side like, oh, my God. Yeah, I think you are there to be the audience reflected, right? You're what everyone at home is like, whoa. So I think it was good to have you there being that other piece. of the conversation. Yeah. But, you know, the episode was supposed to end there.
非常感谢。你知道，自从它第一次播出后我就没再看过。当我观看时，我真的为自己感到骄傲。你应该的。我当时想，天哪，我喜欢这段表演被录下来，我可以以后再看，因为它真的让我觉得我是一个好演员。我当时想，哦，看看我。你是一个好演员。我为自己感到骄傲。你应该有这种感觉。你应该的。嗯，我一直很好奇为什么他们让我坐在Jim旁边，而不是让Karen坐在他旁边。然后那一刻以Jim直视前方结束，而我有点看向一边，就像，天哪。是的，我想你在那里是为了反映观众，对吧？你是家里每个人的写照，哇。所以我认为有你在那里作为对话的另一部分是很好的。是的。但是，你知道，这一集本应该在那里结束的。
In the script, that's the end of the episode. But we added a little tag back on the bus, singing on the bus. And this tag confused a lot of people. Well, it's daytime. We're clearly happy. None of this has happened. It doesn't make any time sequential sense, right? Yes.
在剧本里，那是这一集的结尾。但我们在公共汽车上加了一个小尾声，在车上唱歌。这个尾声让很多人感到困惑。嗯，那是白天。我们显然很开心。这些都没发生过。这在时间顺序上没有任何意义，对吧？是的。
Everyone wanted to know, did you sleep at the beach? You're all in the same clothes. How does everyone look like they've bathed if they spent the night at the beach? They just threw this tag on the end. It was an extra little bit of fun from the episode. It was not meant to be sequential. Yeah. We did not spend the night at the beach story-wise.
每个人都想知道，你们在海滩上睡觉了吗？你们都穿着同样的衣服。如果他们在海滩上过夜，怎么每个人看起来都像洗过澡一样？他们只是在最后加了这个尾声。这是这一集中额外的一点乐趣。它并不是按顺序排列的。是的。从故事上讲，我们没有在海滩上过夜。
Yeah, they just, in editing, they liked it. They liked to end on this sort of upbeat, you know, there's this huge emotional moment has just happened. And then it's us all as a group. And Ed said in the DVD commentary that he started the song, The Flintstone, on the bus. And for him, it was a nod to planes, trains, and automobiles. Which I love. I love that, too. You know, they do something similar in the Valentine's Day episode. They had that little bit of extra footage of Steve improvising in front of the theater. And they threw that bit on the end as a tag for Valentine's Day. So it's just something we did sometimes. Yeah. And I think you can get away
是的，他们在剪辑时喜欢它。他们喜欢以这种欢快的基调结束，你知道，刚刚发生了巨大的情感时刻。然后是我们作为一个整体。Ed在DVD评论中说，他在公共汽车上开始了那首歌，《摩登原始人》。对他来说，这是对《飞机、火车和汽车》的致敬。我喜欢这个。我也喜欢。你知道，他们在情人节那一集中也做了类似的事情。他们有Steve在剧院前即兴表演的额外片段。他们把那段作为情人节的尾声加在最后。所以这只是我们有时会做的事情。是的，我想你可以
with that in a cold open and a tag. They sort of can be their little standalone moments. But Jenna, before we wrap this up, I wrote about some of my memories of filming this episode in my journal. And I said, one of the things I loved is that Rashida and I had our trailers side by side in the parking lot. And we weren't very far away. We were just really close to the catering truck. And so in the morning, Harold Ramos would get his coffee. and Jen and they would have to walk past Rashida and I and we would sit on like the front steps of my trailer like it was our front stoop right? Yeah. And we would visit in the mornings
在开场白和尾声中这样做。它们可以成为各自独立的时刻。但是Jenna，在我们结束之前，我在日记里写了一些关于拍摄这一集的记忆。我说，我喜欢的一件事是Rashida和我的拖车在停车场并排。我们离得不远。我们离餐饮车很近。所以早上，Harold Ramos会去拿他的咖啡，Jen他们会经过我和Rashida，我们会坐在我拖车的台阶上，就像那是我们的前廊一样，对吧？是的。我们会在早上和
with Harold and Jen and I have a photo of us and you know having our coffee in the morning. I just love it. I love that. I love that memory so much. I don't know if we can say enough what an honor and pleasure it was to work with him. But Jen also mentioned this in one of her audio clips what it meant to her to have the opportunity to work with him. I'm so glad he was the person in charge of this crazy, crazy episode. Yes, because he was such a delight. Jenna, I remembered as I was going through photos, do you remember, because him and Jen had to be kind of far away where we were filming, that he had a microphone and he would give sort of big general notes on this microphone and then we would yell at him to tell us jokes and he would
Harold和Jen聊天，我有一张我们早上喝咖啡的照片。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢那个记忆了。我不知道我们是否能充分表达与他共事是多么荣幸和愉快。但Jen也在她的一个音频片段中提到了与他共事对她意味着什么。我很高兴他是这个疯狂、疯狂剧集的负责人。是的，因为他真是太令人愉快了。Jenna，我在翻看照片时想起，你还记得吗，因为他和Jen在我们拍摄的地方必须离得比较远，他有一个麦克风，他会用这个麦克风给出一些大的通用笔记，然后我们会对他大喊大叫让他给我们讲笑话，他会
tell us jokes and in the DVD rain they said that rain would say tell us more about groundhog day he would share little bits of trivia on this microphone to us as we were way far away on the beach and he just made it all so fun well jen mentioned that he was really instrumental in mentoring her. And actually, Sam, why don't you play that clip? One moment, another thing that happened on that episode was there was a, it was a challenging episode because we had a lot to get and the elements were tricky too. I remember it was like incredibly cold and there were heat lamps and it was also scorching hot sometimes and within the course of one day. So there were a lot of additional challenges to that episode. And there was one day where it was like, we were not going
给我们讲笑话。在DVD里，Rain说Rain会说“多给我们讲讲《土拨鼠之日》”，当我们在海滩上离得很远时，他会通过这个麦克风给我们分享一些小花絮，他让一切都变得非常有趣。嗯，Jen提到他在指导她方面真的很有帮助。其实，Sam，你为什么不播放那个片段呢？片刻之后，那一集发生的另一件事是，这是一个具有挑战性的剧集，因为我们要拍的东西很多，而且环境也很棘手。我记得当时冷得难以置信，有加热灯，有时又酷热难耐，都在一天之内。所以那一集有很多额外的挑战。有一天，我们几乎
to make our day by sunset. We had just way more to shoot than was actually possible to shoot in that day with our challenges. And he said to me at one point, Jen, let's like divide up. You work with the actors and I'll do the tech stuff. And it was only for a brief amount of time, but it was just a thrill of mine that I was able to do that and kind of start talking to the actors in a slightly different way and start thinking about the course of being a director. And it all started with that episode, him giving me a little bit of that responsibility because there was just too much to get done. I'm so grateful for Harold, and it's one of the biggest thrills.
无法在日落前完成当天的拍摄。我们有太多东西要拍，以至于在当天的挑战下根本不可能完成。他在某个时刻对我说，Jen，我们分工吧。你和演员一起工作，我来处理技术方面的事情。那只是一小段时间，但我能做到这一点，并开始以稍微不同的方式与演员交谈，并开始思考导演的过程，这让我感到非常激动。这一切都始于那一集，他给了我一点责任，因为实在有太多事情要做了。我非常感谢Harold，能和他一起工作是我职业生涯中最大的兴奋点之一。
of my career that I got to work with him. And guys, Jen ended up directing two episodes of The Office. She directed Crime Aid and the Promotion. It just fits so perfectly that he extended that to her and shared that with her. And how lucky were we? Yeah. Well, guys, that's Beach Games. That is Beach Games.
的职业生涯中，我能和他一起工作。伙计们，Jen最终执导了两集《办公室》。她执导了《犯罪援助》和《晋升》。他把这个机会延伸给她并与她分享，这真是太合适了。我们是多么幸运啊？是的。好吧，伙计们，这就是《海滩游戏》。这就是《海滩游戏》。
Thank you so much for listening. This was so wonderful to rewatch. I loved it. I loved it. This was one of my favorite weeks to prepare. Me too. For sure. Yeah. And to shoot. We got to live it and relive it. What a gift. Well, next week, we have a really big week. It's the job. And we're wrapping up season three. Now, we're going to divide the job into two parts because it's an hour-long episode. We're going to have the job part one and the job part two, but it's all going to be good. All right, guys. We'll see you next week. Have a good one. We love you. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jorkins, and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
非常感谢你们的收听。重温这一集真是太棒了。我喜欢它。我喜欢它。这是我准备的最喜欢的几周之一。我也是。当然。是的。还有拍摄。我们得以生活并重温它。真是份礼物。好吧，下周，我们有一个非常重要的一周。是《工作》那一集。我们要结束第三季了。现在，我们要把《工作》分成两部分，因为它是一个小时长的剧集。我们将有《工作》第一部分和《工作》第二部分，但这都会很棒。好了，伙计们。我们下周见。祝你们过得愉快。我们爱你们。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。这一集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由Jenna Fisher和Angela Kinsey制作。我们的执行制片人是Cassie Jorkins，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是Molly Nugent。Odyssey的执行制片人是Leah Reese Dennis。
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. Thank you. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由Bill Schultz混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是Creed Bratton的《Rubber Tree》。谢谢。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。